okay good morning we're going to get
started
soon
all right good morning welcome to the
special committee on housing we have one
public hearing scheduled for 9:00 so
we're going to get going with that but
Allegiance Scott do it I pledge Alle to
the flag of the United States of America
and to the repblic for it stands
na
for wonderful so we have a um pretty
full day so we're going to start with a
public hearing I was told by the clerk
we're not allowed to start um a work
session until it's notice so
unfortunately we'll have to wait until
11: for that but I believe that I can
get together with the ranking member um
and the caucuses can happen in the
meantime if there's extra time um and
then at 11: we'll have a full committee
work session we have a few amendments on
bills uh I have a couple as well um so
we can discuss those and then if we are
comfortable enough we can exec some
bills at 1:00 so with that I'm going to
open the public hearing on hb1 1291 and
I want to welcome the prime sponsor to
your committee representative Reed thank
you Mr chair and thank you honorable
members for the record my name is Ellen
Reed I represent Rockingham ten which's
New Market and new Fields um the
background of this bill which was um a
almost identical Bill introduced last
year uh was that several years ago and I
want to be clear it was before uh 2020
it was 2018 or 2019 a constituent of
mine reached out to me because he wanted
to put a a essentially what we call an
ad or an in-law suite um in his existing
detached garage so not building any more
infrastructure than already existed but
just put it a place for his aging mother
to live and the town had denied him
because the existing detached garage
didn't happen to be attached to the
primary dwelling and he wrote to me
saying what sense does this make in this
current housing crisis and remember it
was 2019 before the current current
housing crisis um and and his argument
was was quite solid so I reached out to
my then Town planner and said why are we
interpreting the law which uh the
current law as it existed as it exists
is from a law change a bill from about I
think 12 years ago um which guarantees
one Adu by right to every property
owner um but it says that the town can
require that it be attacked Ed and I
would asked my town planner at the time
um who is since left the position why
were we interpreting it interpreting
this in this overly restrictive way when
it really didn't change the rural
character you don't know if someone's
living in a garage when you drive past
and she told me and I said because we
need to we need to provide more
affordable housing for people and people
need to be able to build housing to do
that and she said oh those people we do
enough for those people people they have
the trailers in the apartments that's
what she said to me and even though I am
the state representative for that town I
happen to live in an apartment so I said
I am one of those people so I set about
to change the fact that towns were
allowed to be overly restrictive with
adus um I introduced the bill almost
identical to the current uh version
before you last year it went to a
different committee um but this
committee heard multiple hearings um
information gathering hearings from
multiple organizations most of which
presented information about the
necessity of adus and how they really
help fill what we call the middle uh the
missing middle for
housing and it turns out States
everywhere because the housing crisis
isn't just in New Hampshire but the
entire country it's especially severe in
New Hampshire but States everywhere are
making these types of changes uh making
towns loosen up on their restrictive
zoning and in in particular on
adus um in particular we heard a very
indepth presentation on adus from uh The
mercus Institute from George Mason
University so adus are and these are
accessory dwelling units as you know the
lwh hanging fruit of increased Supply
because it is homeowners who build a use
they tend to be high quality because
they don't want to add something of
inferior quality to their own home and
they tend and they may in fact intend to
move into it later themselves so they
tend to be high quality they tend to be
uh low cost for the renter because
instead of it being a kind of corporate
landlord or a landlord that's in the
business of being a landlord it's
usually a person who just owns their own
home and wants to help uh defay the cost
of their own mortgage so because of that
they are typically high quality and low
cost which is exactly what we need um
they are also the gentlest density that
you can find because when you add an Adu
to a piece of property you usually don't
even know it's there you drive by and
it's in a garage or it's in a barn or it
just looks like a slightly bigger house
than it did before and you don't realize
it's an actual
apartment the people who rent adus often
have better relationships with their
landlords often have use of a yard
gardening ability to have pets because
they work in those relationships with
their landlord so all around it's a
win-win and for homeowners it is a huge
win because not only can they help um
the people who already have an Adu it
helps to fray their own mortgage but as
someone who wants to purchase a home it
helps you buy a home if you can get
rental income as part of the
consideration of your morgage
morgage so very few of the solutions
that we talk about when we talk about
the housing crisis help people buy homes
but home ownership is really the gold
standard not just rentals we talk about
things like large uh apartment complexes
that are lowincome and and other things
that people bulk at and it's not only
the people who have the nice houses in
those communities that bulk at it I can
tell you as someone who's lived in those
apartments almost all my life they're
not great to live in either most people
would rather live in an Adu than a big
complex but for those like I said I
really want to reiterate this because
it's important for those who are looking
to buy their own home and Home Ownership
is something that the more it increases
the more it benefits the entire
Community across the board across pretty
much every metric it helps people having
the ability to build an Adu helps people
buy homes so as I said the law that it
current as it currently stands is every
homeowner has the right to build one Adu
the town can restrict it if it's not
attached and there are some other Common
Sense restrictions towns can can impose
like water and and uh and
septic um I will now this entire
committee not only heard hearings
informational hearings from
organizations but we had three work
sessions to Workshop this particular
language I have submitted this bill
according to the exact language that
this committee did a straw poll on um so
I will just quickly knowing that you all
um as of last late last year already
went through this language I will still
quickly go through this language so
first of all it defines what an Adu is
it's a unit that is on the same lot as
the primary dwelling it can be a
attached which is defined as physically
connected to the the principal dwelling
unit or completely existing within a pre
uh a within a completely within a
pre-existing detached structure because
in those
cases uh they are not adding any
footprint you're not adding to like
affecting the Watershed you're not
building anything new a detached unit
would be neither within uh attached to
the house or within a pre-existing detou
structure and the reason that's defined
that way is because of the language that
comes
later so right now there's one attached
by right uh this will allow that one
attached by right but allow one
additional one the the it will allow one
detached by right and allow one
additional one which then the town may
require to be attached but every
homeowner would now be allowed to build
one detached Adu and then be enti tital
to a second Adu if it is attached but
attached in that case still is within a
pre-existing structure as well so now
you have two adus by right um and also
the setbacks and aesthetic requirements
that town can place on an Adu in this in
this bill cannot be above what is put on
the principal dwelling
unit which is an addition I believe that
mercus then on the next page under uh
Roman numeral 3 uh the original language
is it exists in the law uh said that
interior door would be provided this is
saying that as long as the Adu has the
independent means of Ingress egress
uh that they they shall not limit the
choice of in Ingress and egress meaning
that uh an interior door that connects
required again um other occupancy
standards are not beyond what is um
placed upon the principal dwelling
unit parking this committee uh talked
quite a bit about the parking
requirements that might be placed on an
on an Adu um I believe at the time we
were either 8 to2 or 9 to one that we
were okay with one un one parking space
per Adu being required um because we
were trying to get 100% cons consensus
we decided to go with one parking space
per bedroom however since we had that
meeting it has come to my attention that
that's not even necessarily the
requirement on principal dwelling units
single uh single family homes on their
own and uh we do have another bill that
would reduce it down to one parking spot
per unit across the board and so because
of that I do have an amendment that's
before you that would just bring it down
to a town could require one parking spot
per unit instead of one per bedroom um I
think that makes a lot of sense because
a lot we are trying to really have these
adus fill the missing mle which means
later on as I'll go uh go through we're
also increasing the square footage so
that people can really live in these
long-term
and if you have two bedrooms in your Adu
chances are you're probably you probably
have a
drive um more uh saying aesthetic
standards have to be in line with the
primary structure so the laws that
exists currently says that town cannot
restrict an Adu to below 750 square ft
this raises it to 1,000 square ft for
one of the adus by R and 850 Square F
feet for any other unit again this is
what a town can restrict down to the
town does not have to restrict down to
but they cannot restrict beneath that
level also and this was um in order to
get around the very real problem of many
um units that are being built being
built specifically for the purpose of
short-term rentals and of course those
don't actually add to the supply for our
housing market we are saying that for
the second unit uh a town can say that
the Builder has to rent out at Workforce
housing levels which by default means
that it would not be able to be a
rental again this also allows uh adus to
be converted from existing
structures and I think oh and a town may
require a lot size of no more than 1
half acre in order to have the
additional Adu and that takes us through
the entire bill um essentially the bill
does not at all Impact that first Adu
that people um already have the right to
except to expand the the the size um but
it does allow a second Adu and reduces
the restrictions the town can
place in the creation of this bill both
originally and as we've gone through it
I consult with planners developers
Builders all of whom are very uh
supportive Realtors housing advocat
students really this is one of these
rare situations up here at the state
house where we have people from all
sides coming in in
support people who are both housing
Advocates and also private property
rights Advocates and those two you don't
normally get tenants and landlords
agreeing on much but this is the one
thing that they do agree on and with
that I've basically gone through the
idea and the bones I do want to say
though in general that um we really
really need to do something many states
are taking actions just like this but
New Hampshire is in particularly uh is
particularly impacted by the housing
crisis uh within 20 years we won't have
enough workers and I say young people uh
coming into the state we talk about the
gray of New Hampshire a lot but you have
to understand what young people even
means uh Millennials are in their
40s Millennials have wrinkles and gray
hair and in some cases Millennials have
children who can vote right so but these
are still the workers these are the
people who make our food and serve our
drinks and drive our propane trucks and
uh you can't have it both ways you
cannot have people driving your propane
trucks and making your food and
delivering your mail and then not make
room in your community for those people
so we really really need to do something
to help workers live in this state
because if we don't in 20 years there
won't be enough people work who can work
in this state to take care of all the
people who will be in nursing
homes and with that I'm happy to take
questions thank you representative for
your testimony are questions for
representative
Reed representative D
Lorenzo thank you Mr chair um thank you
for taking my question are you aware
that uh at Market Basket in uh stratum
there are so there are many many open
jobs and so few people willing or able
to work there that they're they have
actually imported people from the
Dominican Republic to work in that store
thank you so much representative for
full disclosure both representative D
Lorenzo and I share a district and so we
both shop at the same Market Basket and
I am actually very familiar with that
because I have repeatedly gone up to the
New Market Basket employees and asked
them where a particular item was and
they were unable to um to communicate
with me because they didn't speak
English very well so you have kind of
hit the nail on the head in terms of
what the problem is we can't get young
people who work into this state to do
the jobs that we need in our communities
and so while I know that there's a lot
of people out there who may have bought
their homes in the 70s or 80s when the
cost of an average home was about one or
two years in average salary that's not
the case anymore it's not even close to
the case anymore and so we can't use
those ideas of what the world was 40
years ago to to go forward from here we
can't get used to that and think that
that those are the ways the communities
are always going to look because we have
to make room for those work workers in
today's market um because if we don't
it's going to be a really bad time in
this state in a few years so thank you
very much I do think that this again is
the lowest hanging fruit of all of the
solutions that we have before
us so okay thank you for your testimony
thank
you Bryce Kawa
Kawa cwo I got
it
all right good morning chair Alexander
and honorable committee members please
pardon the uh typo at the top of my
testimony I wrote this for last time
which says good afternoon um so thank
you again for being here today and for U
making time to hear public testimony on
this issue I'll go ahead and um
introduce myself for the record my name
is Bryce Kao and for the past two years
I've served as chair of the Manchester
planning board past four I've been on
the board um first as an alternate then
as a full member and I'm here to provide
testimony on HB 1291 in my own personal
capacity um so I'd like to mention that
I strongly support HB 1291 relative to
accessory dwelling units Allowed by
Wright and I urge you all to support it
as well uh last year the Manchester
planning board led a push to l Adu
restrictions in the city of Manchester
um those zoning ordinance amendments
were eventually approved and enacted by
our previous Board of Mayor and Alderman
this year under a very different Board
of Mayor and Alderman we are considering
another set of positive changes this
time led by the mayor and our planning
staff the latest proposal would allow
all types of adus to be built uh by
right uh as long as they abide by
certain structural requirements thus
eliminating the need for homeowners to
go before the planning board for a
conditional use permit and the planning
board uh
voted unanimously to support these
updates last month while we're pushing
forward at the municipal level hb1 1291
would help us all push forward at the
state level too uh we are in a housing
crisis as many people have said over the
past months and years and I think we
need to act like it the severity of this
moment means that we must take bold
actions to accelerate Housing
Development and to allow housing
development in the first place removing
barriers for new housing is the absolute
minimum and 8 use are the gentlest form
of density possible and to be fully
honest in my view anyone who opposes
expanding the construction of accessory
dwelling units is simply unserious about
genuinely addressing the housing crisis
so with all of this in mind I ask that
you support hb1 1291 as one important
step of many towards a comprehensive
housing solution thank you for your time
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you for your testimony
representative Damon thank you Mr chair
and thank you for being here and taking
my my question so I'm wondering if you
could clarify would 1291 if it become
statute be different from what
Manchester now has an ordinance I
believe it uh so to clarify it uh
currently the newly proposed zoning
changes have just completed a special
public Hearing in Manchester So
currently uh not all adus are allowed by
right however I'm optimistic that within
the next month they will be um hb1 1291
on top of that would U allow I believe a
second Adu unit whereas under our
proposed zoning changes in Manchester I
believe it is still limited to just one
unit on the property um and the uh bill
sponse would probably be more
knowledgeable about some of the other
minute details um in Manchester we do
currently limit the parking requirements
to just one space per unit um but other
than that I'd be happy to answer other
questions thank
you represent brudy thank you m chairman
uh good morning have have we or the city
of Manchester denied anybody or Adu yet
not to my knowledge there has been some
back and forth over time with regards to
aesthetic concerns um however in those
situations we always came to a solution
and those aesthetic concerns are um
actually encoded in the newly proposed
zoning ordinances so it wouldn't be an
issue moving forward thank
you repres
Kella thank you thank you for taking the
question
um you said that you that the Manchester
is changing their um requirements as far
as adus and you kept on using the word
all like all adus are allowed and then
you went on to say only one is allowed
so can you clarify what do you mean by
all do you mean detached versus attached
yes so attached versus detached versus
internal okay um currently under the
current ordinances that we adopted last
year um we allow internal adus for
example a basement conversion by right
uh does not have to go before the
planning board anything that requires
external construction um is currently
required to go before the planning board
for a conditional use permit the
planning board is very much on board
with the IDE and we're hopeful that the
BMA will approve it um where regardless
of what style of Adu
um like whether it's external or
internal it does not require a
conditional use permit as long as it
abides by the aesthetic requirements
like same materials um No taller than
the principal structure a certain
portion of the principal structure so
it's still accessory that sort of
thing that would be in the zoning
ordinance representative
Damon thank you could you speak to some
numbers for Manchester how present are
adus how much interest there is
something along those yeah we've had
maybe a couple dozen applications over
the past few years for adus um and part
of the limitation in my view is that uh
when people have to go through such a
process it winds up being a bit
intimidating and they're not necessarily
as interested in doing that um however
we don't quite know what the future will
hold um but over the next couple years
we would have an idea like the
difference uh if we do manage to loosen
the restrictions
further represent thank you thank you
for taking another question um have you
experienced
any
uh or aware of any uh requests for a
variance so that a second Adu can be uh
constructed or have have you has anyone
that has uh you know adopted a or put a
Adu in said oh I wish I could have
another one is this is this mostly just
cleanup of the original language or is
there really a desire for additional Adu
that you're seeing on the ground um I
personally have not seen any requests
like that um that would go first to the
zoning board uh and then secondarily to
the planning board and uh so nothing has
made it to the planning board stage at
that point
however um regardless of how I guess
common the desire is for a second unit
um if it is something that this
committee would think is reasonable then
I would certainly encourage you all to
support
it okay thank you for your testimony
GRE thank you Mr chair n Grace for the
municipal Association we we do oppose
this legislation we do have a policy
position to oppose all Statewide land
use mandates and therefore we oppose um
this legislation that would uh impose a
Statewide land use mandate to require uh
additional adus as well as detached
adus um I have submitted written
testimony so you should have that in
front of you and I also uploaded that
online a couple weeks ago um I do want
to address a couple points in of the
bill that are not in the written
testimony
um I or I guess more shortly in the
written testimony um I do want to thank
the prime sponsor for reaching out um
and talking with me about some of our
concerns um and I do think that it is
important as you work towards a solution
to the housing shortage that you do
consider how um the policies you you
pass or uh suggest the House pass um
impacts the type of housing built in
this state um I know that my friend Ben
Frost is behind me and there is one
thing that I certainly agree with him on
which is that we do need a diversity of
housing types in this state um and one
of those is Workforce housing and we've
we've been working very hard with with
him and others to uh come up with
solutions to that and to that end I do
think the provision in this legislation
about um allowing a local option to uh
Target the uh use of the second Adu to
be Workforce housing is important um
because we have seen in communities like
Conway that um there are incentives to
build adus and other structures and then
rent those out as short-term rentals but
at the same time we're hearing from
businesses on Main Street that they
don't have enough
workers um so we need to figure out how
to come up with solutions to that um and
to that end I think that communities
across the state have been doing a very
good job in my written test Tony I
provided you a short list of communities
and online um the the blue highlighted
our actual links to um zoning ordinances
that have passed last year of course
town meeting is um next week so we'll
see uh what additional ordinances may
pass uh across the state but um
communities where we have seen high
levels of development have looked at
adus they've been expanding um and
changing how exactly those are
integrated into their Community um and I
think they're doing a good job um to
that effect um and when you look at kind
of the penetration of adus throughout
the state as compared to other states I
know mercatus uh provided you
information um I summar I I quoted a
short uh set of that information for you
um that really just illustrates that
adus are being adopted at a higher rate
in our state than they are at some other
states where um they've been championed
um and where they have some of these
these these um additional mandates in
place um so we think that the the state
and at the local level were responding
well to uh the demands from the market
in this particular area and I would urge
you to uh reject this legislation I'm
happy to take any questions the
committee may have thank you for your
testimony represent VI Kella thank you
thank you for taking the question um it
seems like your uh testimony is that the
municipalities are doing such a great
job in allowing
adus um and that it's being adopted a
lot uh around the state however
the um are how many municipalities
before the state mandated that they have
adus um were utilizing uh adus and was
that Trend um did the did the New
Hampshire legislature
um you know uh put gasoline on that fire
with with the uh
the the uh mandate that they allow
municip uh adus or or was that happening
pre the state doing anything so uh as
mercus reported uh to the committee I
don't believe anyone was collecting data
on that um I believe that uh Bea is
looking at collecting uh a different
type of reporting um so that they can
keep track of adus I'm not sure whether
that's going to go in effect or not um
but that's not something that's tracked
at the Statewide level so I don't have a
full picture I can tell you anecdotally
from the city of Kean that they adopted
an Adu provision before the legislation
was put into effect back in
2017 um frankly they haven't seen that
many adus being proposed um they they
did adopt uh a couple years ago a very
broad um Prov Vision that that allows I
believe detached um adus it's Linked In
My article um and one of the the things
they just haven't seen an upsell in
demand for that type of development um
they've certainly seen an upswell in
demand of other types of development
multif family units Etc as they've
looked at changing that but they just
haven't seen the the type of demand um I
just don't I don't foresee this having a
significant impact on the housing
shortage
follow thank you um thank you for your
uh comments
it's it definitely does seem from your
from your comments that you're kind of
taking it uh incred for the for the
state's uh mandate however I guess my
question my follow-up for that is um do
you see any of the
um things adjusted in
this uh bill as regarding the regular
first um Adu that it now
be uh requ required to be uh given by
right instead of for the first Adu you
be able to have a require people to go
to uh planning boards and stuff like
that now that all of those that the Adu
kind of
uh is is more familiar by municipalities
do you see that
um there still needs to be for that
first Adu uh public hearing and or going
to the zba and paying paying those fees
and incurring additional cost to to that
development or do you believe that um
moving it to a matter of right is is
appropriate at this time
generally in land use law we've seen
that uh when someone owns a particular
piece of property they want to do any
sort of development on that property um
it's good form to inform the neighbors
and have a hearing so you can determine
whether or not that's an appropriate use
of land um and that is something that
the uh the legislature put into into
effect quite a long time ago and may be
adjusting slightly um in the near future
but
um generally uh you know zoning is is a
a bundle of Rights and part of that is
that you know you have uh collectively
the community comes together to decide
how they they want development to
proceed um where they want development
to proceed and there are you know
obviously different policy options for
that um so you know I don't think moving
moving development to by right um is
necessarily going to change the
direction of development because we're
still going to have to look at the
economic realities of it and I just
don't foresee that this is going to have
a significant impact um even if passed
on um the housing shortage and we've
seen high demand areas um we've seen
more um you know areas where you have
more more jobs more people more uh
Commerce places like uh Manchester where
um they have made uh adjustments um and
so they are doing this type of thing I
just don't foresee a lot of development
occurring
just by simple economics in in very
rural areas um to the same extent that
you would hear um in the urban areas
Provisions representative D Lorenzo
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so um how do
municipalities um distinguish between an
apartment
so I think there are specific
requirements for the Adu with it being
separate um under the building and and
fire codes but I'm not familiar with
those um I believe there's some experts
behind me who could answer your question
better than I could thank
you representative
Gibbs thank you Mr
chair um you've mentioned uh
that municipalities are um uh on their
own going ahead with allowing
adus um but those seem to be uh
Provisions that would allow a single Adu
whereas this proposed uh bill would
allow two adus as of right uh do you see
any likelihood that municipalities will
move from allowing one Adu to allowing
two well I know Enfield has has done so
um I don't know I don't think that's
been an effect long enough to to see
what kind of effect that would have if
any on development there um I believe
that only happened last year but um you
know one of the one of the great things
about local control with zoning is you
get a uh basically functions the same
way at the state level as the states do
for the federal government we get to try
different things see what works and then
good ideas spread naturally so that's
what we that's what we see happening
that's what we hope will happen and I I
here okay thank you thank you for your
please thank you Mr chair members of the
committee thank you for being here today
and thank you for hearing me testify my
name is Vanessa Blaze and I serve as the
director of policy and planning for the
New Hampshire Council on developmental
disabilities our Council by law is
comprised of 60% of people with
developmental disabilities and or their
parents or
Guardians and they are members who are
volunteering for disability Justice and
they believe that the expansion of
rights to build accessory dwelling units
without the barriers of added cost and
additional red tape would have a
positive impact on the lives of people
with intellectual and develop mental
disabilities and the people who support
them as we are aware there is a severe
housing crisis happening in our state
and this crisis disproportionately
affects those in the developmental
disability Community The increased
allowance of construction of adus in our
cities and towns would provide
immeasurable benefits to not only those
in the disability
Community who need long-term housing and
care but also to those who wish to age
in place and to the people who support
them this crisis has forced parents to
reconsider group homes for their adult
children something that New Hampshire
has decided to abolish with the promise
of supporting disabled people to live
self-determined lives independently in
our
communities disabled adults have the
right to Independent Living Spaces even
when they need supports they want to
live in the community with their friends
and their family and have opport unities
to pursue a life of meaning and
engagement adus can serve as an
independent housing while providing them
support and caregiving when
needed the DD council is a federally
funded agency that is dedicated to
dignity full rights of citizenship
cultural diversity equal opportunities
and full participation for all New
Hampshire
citizens the council has identified
affordable and appropriate housing as a
major barrier to living an inclusive
life of meaning we appreciate your
consideration on expanding housing
options and opportunities for people
with disabilities and those who support
them disabled people should not have to
expect to wait longer for safe stable
and appropriate homes where they can
build their lives thank you thank you
for your testimony any
questions representative
Damon thank you thank you for being here
and taking my
question
are there federal funds or other funds
that would help the population you're
representing if adus are legislated to
be easier to create are there federal
funds to help people do that for that
population there are not the uh mandate
from the federal government is that um
housing thank you
represent VI
Kell thank you thank you for taking the
question
um you talked a little bit last time
about
the
the wanting or Desiring of support um
sometimes for people with
disabilities um and the type of of
housing that that that may accommodate
that um and we talked about um like
having people on staff and and uh having
multiple um units where people you know
that person on staff can really um help
possibly multiple people um do you
believe
that that this that this is kind of uh
serving that same purpose or do you or
do you see that this is more about uh
that this would might be apply more
to um uh a family that wants some
Independence uh for uh you know relative
that is disabled and they would be it
wouldn't be necessarily a hired um
person being being uh providing the
services in that case but probably a
family member if if it was utilizing
this structure versus the structure that
we were talking about before
um or if you um if you have any data
about uh or any information about how
often uh currently um adus are being
used for um allowing some you know
independence from from people with
disabilities while having that same uh
support structure I guess readily
available thank you for the question I
believe we believe that the um option of
having adus can serve both the family
unit and um an opportunity to have
support available um within close
proximity um it's also an opportunity to
have um what we think of as lifespan
housing so we having an Adu would give
you a chance to age in place whether or
not you wanted to move into an Adu and
have your natural supports or paid
supports live in the main home or vice
versa
um I don't have exact data on how many
people with developmental disability in
the state are utilizing adus I have
anecdotal data um which the answer is
that um it is one one of the main
solutions that parents mainly are
looking for um it is unfortunately
extremely
expensive and so what we are looking for
is opportunities for people to take
advantage of the ability to build an Adu
without the added cost and without all
of the red tape that people have to go
through right
now quick follow up yeah absolutely so
you talked about the red tape um and
trying to get rid of the red tape um
what specifically I guess is uh my
question is the red tape that you're
seeing is is the most important thing
you know these the that this first Adu
be allowed by right and not have to go
through to a zba meeting or a planning
board meeting and be able to just be
like here's my plan go to the building
in uh inspector and and get your
building permit and start going what
what is the real you know red tape that
you're seeing as the
barrier that's correct being having to
go through the zoning board the planning
board the cost of the permits um even
for many people just understanding the
process um if you don't completely
understand the process you can reach a
point in that process where you have to
go back to the drawing board and every
time you do that it costs more money
thank you representative
Gibbs thank you and thank you for taking
my question uh you mentioned that there
was a federal mandate that funds uh
could not be used for housing uh I
expect those were Health and Human
Services funds um have you looked at HUD
Department of Housing and Urban
Development Federal Department of
Housing and Urban Development funding
for housing for people with disabilities
such as uh the program C SE 8
11 thank you for the question Medicaid
funding cannot be used um towards
housing
um the federal funding that goes through
HUD for Section 8 housing um which is
considered the mainstream Voucher
Program I'm assuming you're referring to
um just the typical uh excuse me no I
was referring to a specific program that
is housing for people with disabilities
called section
811 right um so that is it's not it's
not Section 8 it's a totally different
program right and
um in theory that is a great program
however because of the housing
crisis it is very difficult for people
to actually find a place to live using
the vou V
program um I don't know if you know this
but um the city of conquer is actually
pausing adding people to the wait list
for their voucher program and there's
now 30 families in the city of conquer
who have vouchers but don't have
anywhere to live um I think that's like
a Upstream issue that's an even bigger
issue than this discussion right now um
and I also want to add that uh
section the the voucher program is a
wonderful program however it doesn't
address the needs of people who need
support in order to be able to live
independently followup followup thank
you um uh sorry we're still not quite on
the same page um the section 811 program
that I was referring to is not a voucher
program it's a program to create housing
for people with disability specifically
and it's a competitive program that
organizations have to apply for so I'm
not saying this is something that's easy
to get but I'm just suggesting that it
might be something to look into because
it can actually help you to create
housing rather than just to um uh let
people apply for vouchers which I'm
fully aware can be very difficult to get
and very difficult to use once uh the
applicant has a
voucher thank you okay any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you for your testimony thank
you do you have written testimony okay
thank
Holland
welcome thank you chair and committee
members I appreciate the opportunity to
speak today and um to have this hearing
ing at a time that is not really um
constrained so we appreciate
that um my name is Sarah Holland I'm the
vice chair of public policy for the New
Hampshire Realtors and I am here on
behalf of the Realtors who ask you to
support hb1
1291 this is a private property rights
issue it's the use um if the use of
private property does not create a
health or safety issue and owners should
be able to use the property as they see
fit we're not asking you to allow a
property owner to construct an Adu we're
asking you to memorialize their right to
add an Adu absent a compelling reason
not to which there are seemingly none of
course there is um if there is or when
there is an Urgent health or safety
issue that may negatively impact the
community or the occupants then the
government should of course take action
however before voting we would implore
that you consider the mechanisms that
municipalities already have um and will
retain under this bill to regulate the
health and safety of these
is something that already um regulate is
already regulated by Dees including any
additional occupancy space on a property
so if you um increase your load um then
you need to increase the size of your
septic that is already regulated um if
you cannot increase the size of your
septic then you cannot be approved for
an Adu water if there's no access to
pable water you cannot be approved for
an Adu sufficient space if a property
does not have a spe sufficient space to
add an Adu given a myriad of regulations
like setbacks Wetlands um radii from
private Wells you cannot be approved
from for an
Adu a municipality retains much of its
authority to protect the health and
safety of the occupants and the
community members this bill does not
change that um there have been many
questions about the barriers to adus um
and I'm happy to um discuss some of
those so the current process for which
an Adu or any substantive change to a
property um it
requires a lot of time a lot of effort
from the applicant um it requires
hearings and site plan drawings which
can be expensive to produce and this is
just in the hopes that you'll be
approved there's really no mechanism to
appr approach a land use board and say
hey if I apply will I be approved they
do not like to talk in hypothetical so
you have to go through the process for a
maybe you're unsure if you're actually
going to be approved um in my town um we
did move forward obviously with the um
Adu law that was enacted six years ago
and however mine chose to um restrict or
create additional rules around detached
adus so my house I have um a single
family home on a 1acre lot with a
detached garage um my neighbor has an
attached garage he can build without an
an Adu without any um additional Hoops I
would either need to quadruple the size
of my lot construct a connection between
my garage or my house and my house or I
would need to go through the lengthy
approval process without any guarantees
um I currently have well I do have
three adult children that have
previously left the state to find
employment and housing one has returned
we would love to um help them get into a
house of their own of course the housing
crisis um so we would love to give them
another space to have their privacy and
unfortunately without going through any
of those Hoops we are unable to do that
um this bill will allow us to construct
um an Adu above our garage maybe in in
our basement to allow myself to age in
place um over time to be able to bring
in my aging parents to have our adult
children to have their own space um so
this is um something that we support as
an association but also individually and
to speak to being denied um an
application for an Adu it's not
necessarily that folks are going forward
and being denied these applications it's
that we're looking at this criteria and
self-excluding we're saying that doesn't
fit and I just simply don't have the
time or the resources to go through this
so we feel that um that is why so few
have been built since the law went into
effect in the last six years the hurdles
the confusion and the cost and time
associated with that may be so under hp1
1291 towns retain their local control in
order to relate uh regulate legitimate
health and safety concerns and and it's
also worth mentioning that New Hampshire
is not a home rule state all
municipality Authority regarding zoning
was provided to them by the state of New
Hampshire you um so however they were
granted the authority to diminish an
individual's private property rights by
denying them the right to build an
attached or detached Adu even if there's
no legitimate health or safety rationale
hb1 1291 appropriately gives property
owners some of their property rights
back while the municipalities maintain
reasonable Authority to safeguard their
communities we ask you to support
1291 thank you for your testimony any
questions represent
yella thank you uh thank you for uh
taking the question um I'm sure I will
have a few um have you heard of any
people trying to like in your in your
town um might have a detached garage
with similar type of rules where they
have essentially constructed a large
hallway in between the the uh detach
garage and the primary structure so that
they can kind of get around that rule of
detaching you know that uh
municipalities have kind of created this
arbitrary uh guidance or requirement
that you know there
being interior connecting door or
something along those lines so I have
not heard of that being the case in my
town but that was a consideration our
consideration for hours oh well what is
the cost of US attaching the house does
it or to the garage does that make sense
what will that look like um and then you
know we just self-excluded that we're
not going to move
forward FYI it's happened in my town and
and once you got approved like that that
hallway could theoretically just
disappear um but
the and then it would be
detached Adu um so the
uh the uh it seems like one of your
um one of your main kind of focuses are
are on
this like this real value of the the
change to the first Adu of that that um
both uh the first attached or detached
is allowed as a matter of right um and
that you believe to be maybe the biggest
impact of of this legislation uh is that
correct yeah we we support all of it of
course but the barriers to adding those
adus would essentially disappear with
that first one by right
absolutely Al
set yes no one else
um sure uh thanks for for taking another
question so in
experience in your local municipality um
have you seen or or any that you've
dealt with have you seen any other
restrictions um one of the ones that
jumps out to me seems to be that we are
now not going to allow more than uh
um a minimum lot size of a half acre for
the second uh accessory dwelling that
would not um being com uh that would
make your municipality have to change
their rules as as you kind of previously
stated have
you uh any any thoughts or or concerns
about um
these other types of barriers that
municipalities are putting up whether it
be requiring you to increase the size of
your lot or or
uh um you know parking or whatever the
case may be um that maybe we haven't
addressed fully in this bill that you
see as barriers uh nothing that jumps
out um what my experience is over the
last 12 years in real estate and working
with buyers and sellers and Property
Owners relative to private property
rights is is
that communities can be very creative in
finding ways to ban certain things that
they do not agree with so I think this
is a great place to start I would love
for this to move forward and then we
will just have to address any of the
other issues that come up
later please quick H have you uh in your
experience heard of any desire for the
second Adu is that um getting squ washed
anywhere that you've heard of or or is
it mostly just the access to the first
Adu that is the biggest hurdle to this I
think it's a conversation that's
happening right now regarding the
current housing crisis so as I explained
with my three adult children um and my
aging parents as well as myself over
time um being able to transition within
your own property is a really great
opportunity so um having the first one
by right is a tremendous step having a
sec one second one as we became empty
nesters we had all of this space and a
lot of the conversation was where do we
go now we don't need all of this space
um there's nowhere to go so what do we
do with what we have here and how do we
prepare our family for the future and
just the whole economic Outlook so um I
think a lot of folks are having this
conversation I don't know that it's
actually being um outright band in any
specific way um but being able to
FastTrack it and have it be a viable
option for folks is super
powerful representative Damon thank you
thank you for taking my question could
you speak to what you and your
Association are seeing or have
seen in regards to both presence of and
interest in adus contrasted between our
cities and our rural areas and small
communities I think the need is there
across the board I live in a rural
Community um I work with a lot of
clients that are in more urbanized
communities and the the conversation is
the same we need more housing we need
housing thank you and
separately what input might you have on
adus so the investment piece for the
property owner to um input uh or to
create an Adu in their space um has an
ex expectation of a return on that
investment for them to be able to age in
place live in their homes continue to
stay there and not be forced out um it
creates a marketability if they were to
sell their homes um for folks who are
looking for very similar situations so I
win-win what are you seeing in terms of
people being able
to get a mortgage or or some kind of
financing to add an Adu if they don't
Capital that's a really great question I
I am I'm a realtor I am not um A lender
but um the conversation is happening
we're finding that there are um it's
definitely something that is positive on
the purchase aspect of a property if
there is an Adu you can use that
additional income to qualify for a
property that you may not otherwise
qualify for um to be able to tap into
the equity there are just a lot of
different um mechanisms um but I think
that anyone that is interested that
should have those conversations with a
lender with a Community member to be
able to explore if that is viable for
them
yep so I'm interested in what you could
tell us about the amount of increased
value to a single home that then adds
one or two
adus con not contrasted with but I know
for instance if you remodel your kitchen
your bath you almost always economically
that adds enough value to the house it's
considered
worthwhile how much value do a use add
property it's a hard question to answer
depending on the location and the prop
property specific itself whether or not
it is used as an additional living space
um for a family member or if it is
actually being rented out for income um
so that takes into account but it what
it does is it becomes more attractive
overall to buyers because of the
versatility so um with supply and demand
and the attractiveness of course that is
going to be an increased in increased
value um I have a quick question based
on your experience have you seen um a
diminished property value of the butters
of properties with adus no you have not
seen that no thank you any other
questions thank you for your testimony
marglin thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Alysa Marg I serve as director of
housing action New Hampshire we're in
support strong support of House Bill
1291 and the amendment as well uh the
representative Reed uh introduced that
uh regarding one parking space per unit
instead of per
bedroom um I thought it would be helpful
uh given that you um have already walked
through the details of the bill and
heard strong support from various
constituencies just to talk about our uh
active involvement in the passage of the
original du law back in
2016 um we had partnered then with the
DD Council and
ARP um and help bring forth the voices
about the housing challenges of over
adults and we brought uh uh uh to the
legislature um voices of parents with uh
uh adult children with disabilities
really looking for Adu Solutions at the
time um we also had a governor who had
direct experience with having to um give
up uh Dream Home opportunities in order
to find a municipality that would
accommodate um uh an Adu uh so that um
her her son could uh continue to live
with them I think eight years later we
are really now in a position to improve
this law um Mr Grace brought up um The
mercus Institute and uh I remember I
recall one of your many working sessions
when mercus presented to this committee
and talked about their efforts to have
uh Adu laws uh in every state in the
country um and reviewed our law and said
uh but the New Hampshire law is weak and
I want to acknowledge the sting I felt
that day sitting in your committee room
because of our um our work on it um but
um
um you know I do recall that there were
as as you know so well so many
compromises that were made in order to
push that forward and I think that what
we are essentially saying
is there were too many compromises made
and it's not really working as well as
it could um and uh you know for for an
organization like housing action New
Hampshire we support accessory dwelling
units we're particularly happy to see
that you know for the second Adu here
that a municipality could require income
targeting you know for us it's not the
Silver Bullet like we very much you know
are encouraging multif family
manufactured housing you know diverse
housing stock things you know proposals
that you on this committee have really
explored but we have an Adu law on the
books let's make it work for people and
uh so um and it also you know helps
preserve rural character and Rural
communities it's that um as my colleague
Sarah ritesman who's here today reminds
me you know this is gentle density and
it's very much an aesthetic uh that uh
is useful um to Granite Staters who
already have single family and a and a
good use of um uh current infrastructure
and new infrastructure so we urge your
support and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you for your
testimony represent viella thank you
thank you for uh taking the question
um I happen to be at one of my uh
municipalities budget or or planning
board
um um before I think the final language
of this or maybe even after the final
language of this came out um they
expressed mainly their concern about
um the parking spaces and only being
able to require one if they're you know
if someone is is
having uh three
bedrooms in this Adu if they don't if
they don't cap the size right if they if
you leave it to however much as long as
it's smaller than the house and you have
a giant house you could potentially have
a three-bedroom Adu and if that had two
adults or whatever and maybe an adult
child in it you could potentially have
three cars and they wanted to you
know they said that that was a big
concern essentially for their that
Community um so do you think that that
um that is an unjustified concern and
something that we should you know uh uh
amend for sure and say that's that's you
know unjust ified we're just going to
make that not possible in your
municipality um for you to say like hey
three-bedroom can require three three
parking spaces or whatever um or do you
do you believe that you know the the
compromises let's say with this bill are
actually
significantly um valuable for the first
Adu and and uh that it's that it's uh
positive without that Amendment uhk you
for the question I think it's excellent
one of the reasons I wanted to
articulate our support for
representative Reed's Amendment um is uh
is connected to um one of the CH current
challenges with our current law um you
recall the presentation uh uh regarding
the New Hampshire zoning Atlas just a
really uh important data set that has
come out of the center for ethics and
Society at St ansam college and um they
identified uh communities that have
created uh ordinances that require four
parking spots per Adu and essentially
using that you know to just um as a
barrier you know for uh a private
property rights for for an option for a
homeowner to do something so um because
of that I think you know parking is uh
really important I I I mean I uh I don't
know that housing action you Hampshire
has a position like broadly but I would
say personally I think there is some
Municipal interest in parking but I
think that it's we should have
reasonable um requirements and I think
one per unit makes a lot of sense uh
that the MC the representative MC
Williams bill that you're considering
also makes a lot of sense and um in the
adus in my community um both of them are
uh aging parents who no longer Drive and
they don't use any parking uh so uh just
made room for growing teenage kids in
the in the you know kids house next door
to to use the spot but uh yeah I think I
don't think I I think you should in
incorporate the amendment if you have
the um support on the committee to do
so I'm representative Wallace thank you
chairman and thanks for taking my
question um have you heard any
municipalities say that we have a
parking problem here in New Hampshire or
pretty much the housing problem that we
had to address um I mean I uh I live in
the city of Portsmith and you know
parking is a is a is a hot issue um uh
so but I uh I
don't I think we have a housing crisis
we don't have a parking crisis and I
think um
parking uh the over requirement of
parking is a barrier to to density it's
a barrier to safe saing our natural
spaces and it's often unnecessary I I do
think that there is some Municipal
interest in uh in there but I I I don't
think in this case for an Adu that's not
going to house you know hundreds of
people at a time I think that uh it
there shouldn't be an excessive
requirement around
that okay thank you for your testimony
Frost
welcome thank you Mr chairman and good
morning committee members I'm Ben Frost
I'm the deputy director and chief legal
officer at New Hampshire housing it is
uh a pleasure to be with you this
morning on this beautiful day and to
express New Hampshire housing's
enthusiastic support for house
1291 um you've heard a lot of testimony
about uh need and there have been a lot
of questions asked and I'd like to come
back to some of those questions um as I
as I speak um I'll just note that um as
Alysa marglin uh recounted the 2016
legislation creating the the Adu law uh
was really well supported in the the
House of Representatives a majority of
both Republicans and Democrats voted in
favor of it
um and it was uh largely because of this
this question of property rights what
can individual homeowners do with their
property in a in a reasonable
fashion um accessory dwelling units are
in fact one of the best options we have
to increase uh Supply in and of our
housing and to do so uh really without
public subsidy uh this is up to private
property owners to figure out whether
they want to do it and then if so how to
do it um
and and certainly what we've seen coming
out of the the uh existing law is no
Community being flooded by adus as was
initially suggested uh but really
incremental small scale development
one-off development because it relies on
an individual homeowner to do something
it's not something that developers are
doing large scale it's it's individual
homeowners acting in their own interests
to do
this um
it is as has been called a gentle
density small scale infill uh and yet
despite all of these positive attributes
there are a number of communities that
are making it really really really
really hard uh to do uh accessory
dwelling units the need now is so great
and so urgent that we need to do as much
as we can as soon as we can we can't uh
try just one thing and and hope that it
works and then a few years later say
well it didn't didn't do enough let's do
do something else uh we need to do many
things now House Bill 1291 is one of
those things we also can't rely solely
on the good graces of places like
Manchester and Kean which are doing uh
awesome things um it requires proactive
legislation like this if you really want
to achieve something that is to address
uh the state's uh housing Supply crisis
then it makes to eliminate the barriers
to doing that and house B 1291 does
that um I'd like to turn to a couple of
questions that have already been asked
and I'll start with um representative
Damon you asked about the economics of
accessory dwelling units and financing
um I'm delighted to say that the
Brookings institution just in the past
week published an analysis of uh the
economics of accessory dwelling unit l
just uh in in the Los Angeles area and I
say well that's Los Angeles well okay
money is money uh and the economics of
development in Los Angeles although it's
higher there than it is in New Hampshire
it's still dollars for dollars or
dollars so I think that the analysis
done by brookens is um highly
instructive and it indicates that even
without subsidy there is some room for
homeowners to do this in a way that is
is profitable uh C certainly the they
they also argue that it's helpful to
have subsidies such as a housing Choice
voucher uh to accompany that but it's
not absolutely necessary regarding
financing I'm also really happy to say
that the uh Federal housing
Administration has uh recently in the
past year changed uh some of its
underwriting standards and so we see uh
programs uh lending programs coming
forth from Fanny May and Freddy Mack
that allow for the income associated
with uh accessory dwelling units that is
the rental income to be counted as part
of the the financing of a mortgage uh so
this is and that would go for
refinancing as well and I know that uh
they and others other uh federal
agencies and also banks are looking at
uh opportunities to leverage this
because of the need because of the
opportunity that people have one of the
difficulties right now is the relatively
higher interest rates uh we're
experiencing now in comparison to the
past couple years just bear in mind
interest rates right now historically
speaking are pretty good they're just
not 3% U which is what we had come uh
we' become accustomed
to um regarding the issue of parking uh
in rep interview Kelly you you asked
this question about one space per Adu
and I want to direct you to to um the
the bill language which talks about uh
this is the bill as introduced uh page
three page two line 20 an additional
parking space for each accessory
dwelling unit
bedroom that's the existing language in
in the the bill so it is it flexes based
upon the number of bedrooms per
accessory dwelling unit so I think this
this issue of parking representative
Wally who said do we do we have a
parking problem is a red herring frankly
raised by a lot of
communities um if you look at single
family homes and how municipalities deal
with permitting of single family homes
it's pretty much hands-off other than
the building permit is it allowed by
zoning if yes then you pull the building
permit you build the
house accessory dwelling units are
intended to be an extension of a single
family home thus the word EX accessory
it's accessory to a single family home
so those communities that are uh you
know saying yes we want single family
homes and I think that is probably 234
out of 234 Incorporated municipalities
in the
State uh are not for the most part
regulating parking of those so why is it
that suddenly with accessory dwelling
units we're going to see a flood of cars
it's not going to happen unless you have
a family that has cars and I look at
single family homes in my town without
accessory dwelling un it's small homes
modest homes might have five or six cars
all registered all legal uh just parked
in the yard if this is a concern it's
not about the accessory dwelling
unit and if it is a concern in a
municipality then regulate how you do it
with single family family
homes
um regarding um representative D Lorenzo
you had asked about the difference
between an accessory dwelling unit and
an in-law apartment there is no
difference there is absolutely no
difference we used to call them in-law
apartments or mother-in-law apartments
or something like that Granny Flats uh I
think that's an Australian term um and
uh that essentially has gone by the
Wayside because the current accessory
dwelling unit law uh prohibits
municipalities from from requiring a
familial relationship between the
occupants of the primary dwelling unit
and the accessory unit uh so they there
does not have to be a family
relationship between them so we used to
call it that we don't need to
anymore um representative y Kelly you
asked about the the prospect of a long
breezeway well I got that question from
the planner some a few years ago in Wolf
bro who who called me and said well we
have has to be attached under the
current law uh so he asked me well I get
this guy who's proposing a 300 foot
Breezeway these these
ridiculous attempts to
overcome an unnecessary regulatory
barrier are the result of that
unnecessary regulatory barrier which is
limiting uh what is allowed to attached
accessory dwell units house built 1291
by allowing detached accessory dwelling
units eliminates that that uh illogical
absurd
result um representative Gibbs is not
here but um I'll I'll talk with her uh
separately but I do want to point out uh
the the state's 811 program uh it New
Hampshire housing is the entity that is
able to apply to the federal government
for funding through the 811 program
we're using that in response to the
state's 2014 settlement uh which dealt
with people with serious mental illness
in re Amanda d uh and we we use that in
collaboration with the Department of
Health and unit services to provide
housing uh new housing or or units in
existing housing for people with serious
me mental illness so that that is an
active program and we've just applied
for uh new funding in the current
round um I think I've said enough and
I'll stop here happy to take any
questions any questions represent mcon
thank you Mr chairman um in back in the
beginning of your conversation thank you
for taking the question you talked about
a recent study that came up in the
Brookings Institute but I I missed what
that was in reference
to representative makoni that is in
reference to the cost of construction of
accessory dwelling units and whether it
makes economic sense for a homeowner to
do it and the conclusion was uh
generally yes it does make sense and I'd
be happy to supply a link to that to the
committee thank
you representative D Lorenzo thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question so you mentioned section 811
I'm familiar with 811 but I wasn't aware
that it could be scattered site units is
that
correct representative D Lorenzo it I
think it could be scattered site we use
it in in uh connection to our other
financing programs for multif family
housing construction so for example we
give points to developers in the
qualified allocation plan which is the
low-income housing tax credit funding
program uh we give points to developers
who say they're going to dedicate
uh X number of units to people who uh
would be receiving 811 uh rental support
okay great thank you represent
yo thank you thank you for taking the
question um so you seem to
uh agree that the the bill as introduced
addresses uh appropriately the concerns
of one of my municipalities as far as
parking however the amendment
proposed um seeks to change that to uh
something that is
not might bring more concern and
heartbreak and and heartburn I guess for
for my municipality do you believe that
that that
concern is it correct to believe that
that that you your uh testimony saying
that that concern is unfounded um and
and we should adopt the amendment or
that that that in the rare case that the
municipality does have that concern that
they should be able to to do it per
bedroom uh representative I support the
amendment um I I do believe that as I
said before it's it's a red herring it's
something that municipalities some
municipalities raise as a means of
saying well we we can't do that at all
because this uh remotely uh likely thing
might happen at some point in the future
we can't do any of it uh that seems to
me to um be the wrong approach if and I
I'll repeat this if a municipality
believes that it has a parking problem
associated with single family homes then
it should regulate that not stop
accessory dwelling unit
development
represent Damon thank you thank you for
being here and helping us sort through
this you spoke early in your testimony
about municipalities that have put
difficulties in place with the existing
Adu
law does this version should it go
forward address all or most of those
concerns thank you for that question
it I think it addresses many of the
concerns and and representative Ella has
been asking is is this your is this your
top issue uh I I'd say the top two uh
issues that I see are the special
processes uh so conditional use permit
or special exception uh it's you know um
uh was said earlier that the these these
pose barriers uh to homeowners seeking
to do this with their these sorts of
things with their properties uh and
oftentimes um it people just say no I'm
I'm not gonna I don't want I don't want
to go before the zba uh it's it's too
daunting a
proposition um so I
think allowing at least one accessory
dwelling unit by right is essential to
allowing these things to happen uh also
allowing that to be a detached accessory
dwelling unit so i' say those are my two
top
ones thank you very much for your
Taylor good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee I'm Nick Taylor
I'm the executive director of the
workforce Housing Coalition of the
greater Sea Coast we're a nonprofit that
works in straford and Rockingham County
seeking to advance diverse housing
options attainable to our Workforce
thank you for all the time you spent on
this bill both today and and I know over
the past few months um we're here in
strong support of House Bill
1291 accessory drilling units broadly
and then this bill specifically provide
incredible benefits uh to the housing
market and I'll run through a couple
points here on affordability as has been
mentioned you know we certainly have an
affordability challenge in our state and
this is an option that is more
attainable to our Workforce without
additional subsidies so it allows it to
come forward as needed on the
construction affordability point in
addition to what Mr Frost said we have
talked with Community Banks in our
region who are interested in putting
together Adu specific lending programs
that help make it more financially
feasible to construct them their
questions are how do we mitigate the
risk from a public hearing process where
something could be denied after someone
has put thousands of dollars in
permitting fees through our architecture
and engineering fees as well as what is
the demand and so I think we can see
that there's a demand and by mitigating
the risks it'll make it more likely that
folks of all income levels and not just
those that can afford to front some
money uh will be able to afford to build
additional accessory dwelling units um
in addition as has been mentioned this
is a pro property rights you know issue
and that allowing folks to construct
additional accessory dwelling units
allows them to make a decision with
their property that bests fits the fits
the need of their family that may be a
home for an aging parent it may be a a
child returning from from college or
back to the home or it may be just for
additional income stream for them to be
able to stay in their home and stay in
their Community finally you know this
kind of question of how will it affect
the community and what is the demand
will this actually get built as has been
mentioned you know this is a great
gentle density it's a great infill
option that really doesn't change the
feel of any sort of community or
neighborhood while adding add additional
housing Supply the center for uh the
stam College Center for ethics and
society and their annual housing survey
asked the question of have you
considered building an accessory
dwelling unit 10% of folks said they
already did 35% said they had considered
it but ran into regulatory or financial
barriers and that is what stopped them
from moving things forward so again
there's clearly a demand and there's
almost a little over 400,000 single
family homes so even if just 10% of
those folks who are interested built an
Adu that would be another
40,000 uh housing units for this state
that is desperately needed so this bill
will make an impact we think there's a
lot of great pieces in here it's great
for our businesses great for our economy
and will increase choices amongst
renters and homeowners so we hope your
support and happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony represent
viella hi thank you um it was said
earlier
that um municip we're not seeing a flood
of adus um come in and there was hinted
that there's um some
barriers um for a devil's advocate um
approach the the nhas is in their
testimony is saying that that uh
Durham uh has one in
nine uh single family h houses in Durham
have an Adu I guess the question is
isn't that already saturation and um in
that municipality and if we made it
super easy is are we looking at like a
one and two like a very very just like
every single house in in New hampsh in
Durham is is uh has an Adu and there is
no place in Durham that is you know
single family home anymore I think
realistically we need to and thank you
for the question increase a whole bunch
of housing options and you know living
in sort of the reality of needing the
private property owner to decide that
this is the right thing to do you know
you I don't think you'll be in a
situation where every home has an
accessory dwelling unit on it and the
sort of Patchwork of local restrictions
has I think lowered the the interest or
or at least put up some barriers for
other communities and other individuals
who want to explore this option but just
run into hurdles and don't have the time
to look through or go through a public
that represent D Lorenzo thank you Mr
chair and good great to see you Nick and
here's my question um you mentioned a
poll a research poll asking folks if
they were interested in adding an Adu
which poll is that yes thank you for the
question it's from the St ansam College
Center for ethics housing uh voter
attitudes on housing affordability
survey from 2023 oh great thank you is
is that a St anom College poll like the
way they do typical polls or is was that
like
a like it was a scientific poll it was a
scientific because I know sometimes they
just like put something out and to fill
it out no it was scientific thank you I
appreciate that okay any other questions
thank you for your
mushin
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you so much uh my name
is Matt mushan I live in Claremont and I
serve as the excuse me my name is Matt
musian I live in Claremont I serve as
the advocacy and engagement director
with 603 forward a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization dedicated to engaging
activating and empowering young people
across New Hampshire and today I'm here
to testify on behalf of 603 Ford in
support of House Bill 1291 which would
ow a second accessory dwelling unit or
Adu by right and reduce restriction on
restrictions on adus and just to start
with a personal story I live in a home
with an Adu my partner's family lives
with us and without our Adu and him we
we just wouldn't be able to afford our
home and he would have a very hard time
uh foring a place on his own and also I
would not have him to watch my dog when
I come down to uh to speak with all of
you which I'm sure we all are grateful
for um but you know it's no secret that
with the growing deficit in housing in
New Hampshire it affects us all
homeowners renters business owners um
but particularly the situation is
placing a heavy burden on young folks in
our Workforce as you've heard today and
in my job I meet with young people in
New Hampshire all the time who share
their stories of struggle trying to find
safe affordable housing um and folks
like Michael who gave me a story that I
could share today uh he said quote it's
a real struggle to afford housing these
days especially when all the prices are
geared toward households with two or
more incomes it leaves people like me
stranded with no option other than
living in a car in a Walmart parking lot
or at a highway rest stop which is what
I've resorted to doing since leaving my
apartment it's not how a hard person
hard working person should be forced to
live and um as you've also heard
accessory dwelling units already are
playing a really crucial role in
addressing the housing needs in New
Hampshire by providing smaller uh more
naturally affordable housing options and
research does show that in many states
accessory dwelling units continue to uh
rent for less than market rate rentals
um so in conclusion by allowing
homeowners to build either an attached
or detached Adu on their property in
removing burdensome regulations we can
diversify our housing Supply with more
affordable housing options tailored to
individuals at uh different stages of
life um with a more and with a more
diverse array of housing choices people
will have the opportunity to find and
afford a home that suits their specific
needs um so I hope you will support this
bill hb1 1291 makes small changes to
existing laws to remove barriers uh that
currently make it difficult for
homeowners to build these units and uh
we hope that you'll be part of a
solution to address New Hampshire's
housing crisis thank
you thank you for your testimony are
there any questions represent viell
thank you thank you for taking the
question you said that you have an uh
Adu currently um have you sought out um
the opportunity to have a second Adu as
this this bill might allow and were
denied or or would you put in a Adu a
second Adu in your uh situation if you
you had the
opportunity uh I mean certainly look
into it we haven't currently um you know
our needs are pretty well met but if it
was a possibility I don't see why we
wouldn't look into it if uh if the
opportunity
allowed okay any other questions thank
you for your Tes thank you very
much sales Casten I hope I pronounced
that
right um good afternoon chair and
members of the committee I'm sales cast
and I live in do I'm here as the
executive director of New Hampshire
youth movement and here to testify and
support um we have a major housing
shortage in New Hampshire um we need
20,000 units in the next few years just
to keep up with demand um and unless
we're using all our resources to the
best of our ability we'll never meet
that goal there are a lot of young
people in New Hampshire who want to stay
here uh but if there's no housing for
them they'll be forced to leave uh this
crisis is affecting real people a number
of my close friends have had to leave
Dober uh where I live both because of
the prices and also because there just
weren't units available I myself am
staying in a less than ideal apartment
because my roommates and I don't have
another place to move to and um this
crisis is affecting young people who are
getting out of school and want to stay
here uh and families who are looking to
buy homes for the first time and put
down
Roots um accessory dwelling units
provide an opportunity to young people
to stay in New Hampshire um on a
previous hearing day a number of
students and people in their early 20s
came to speak in favor of adus many of
them couldn't be here today so they
submitted written testimony instead in
those testimonies you'll hear similar
arguments you've heard today they are
struggling to find housing considering
leaving the state because of it and that
removing burdensome regulations on adus
is an important creative way for us to
increase housing Supply and address New
Hampshire's housing crisis the last
thing I'll say is just thanks to the
members of the committee I know you've
worked really hard and put in long hours
um to come up with possible bipartisan
solutions to address the housing crisis
like hb1 1291 that's not easy not every
committee is able to do that and at the
end of the day making sure people
families can have a place to live in New
Hampshire that's not a partisan thing
it's an important thing and I'm glad you
see it that way too uh thanks very much
thank you for your testimony any
questions thank
row welcome hi thank you for having
having me and allowing me to present my
testimony to you all
today my name is Abby row I come from
Rochester and I'm here today because I
wanted to speak to the renters
experience here in New
Hampshire I'm here in favor of HB
1291 I was born with the genetic disease
that's left me unable to work and care
for myself like the typical
person because of this my welfare is is
heavily dependent upon both the state
and federal governments this leaves me
seriously limited when it comes to
housing especially here in New
Hampshire I've personally struggled with
housing for the last 5
years we also live in a time where the
reality is that a lot of adult children
are living with or renting from their
parents because rents are so high they
cannot afford to live on their own I can
no longer afford to live in Dover I
certainly can't afford to live in
Portsmith or Greenland and I can barely
afford to live in Rochester now so I'm
not sure where I'm going to go as rents
continue to go
up um please also consider that the lack
of housing options means that sometimes
renters are forced to stay with
landlords who may not have the most
ideal practices
or maybe even abusive practices because
where are they to go so it really takes
power away from the renter and the
person in that position of renting what
am I supposed to do when my
landlord doesn't doesn't meet my basic
needs because it's a process to have
that addressed in a legal way and the up
the other alternative is to find
additional
housing I'd also like to put forward
that right now now I'm living my highest
quality of life because I was able to
find an Adu to rent that Adu has
provided me with rent control it has
provided me with access to people
because I have special needs that are
not typical I have people on site if I
need
them
um so in short I'm in favor of hb1 1291
because it creat creates affordable
alternative housing options for all New
Hampshire residents and it puts some
power and control back into
renters uh thank you board for your time
and energy
today thank you for your testimony would
you like to answer questions oh I
actually have to get to a doctor's
appointment thank you for your testim
thank you no
problem okay Alexa
welcome thank you good morning chairmen
and members of the special
committee um and thank you for hearing
my testimony today my name is Alexa
Carpenter I'm a resident of Manchester
New Hampshire the town that I call home
and where I grew up today I become I
come before you as an educated young
professional working two different jobs
yet still finding it impossible to
afford board housing in the community
that I grew up in and with that I'm here
today to testify in support of House
Bill 1291 relative to accessory dwelling
units and my reason is pretty much
straightforward um I support any
legislation that will decrease barriers
to smart and sustainable development and
increase housing options for folks like
myself who have been stifled by the lack
of affordable and available housing in
our state and this is exactly what this
bill intends to do
as someone looking to find a place of my
own in New Hampshire I've paid close
attention to the efforts underway on the
state and local level to make this
possible for people like myself and more
than anything it's been incredibly
disheartening to see how contentious
something as essential as housing has
become in political dialogues housing
and shelter is not a choice it's a
necessity and there are things that we
can do to increase its accessibility in
the state this being one of those
things it's no secret that New Hampshire
has some of the most restrictive
regulatory barriers in the country and
this bill will go a long way to
alleviate the impact of these
long-standing barriers on housing access
in the state and I know I speak for many
young folks when I say as much as I'd
love to live in the community I grew up
in live near my family and be a resource
to my aging parents no roof overhead is
where sacrificing all um access to
groceries medication uh Financial
Security to obtain it we need affordable
and attainable housing and we need it
now if the state has a chance at
retaining the next generation of workers
problem solvers and change makers like
yourself in in conclusion House Bill
1291 offers a practical and sustainable
solution to the housing crisis in New
Hampshire and by endorsing this
legislation we are not just addressing
the current challenges but also laying a
groundwork for a more secure and vibrant
future for all people that call this
place home thank you thank you very much
for your testimony any questions seeing
none thank you all right my last speaker
Walker welcome thank you chairman and
members of the committee uh thank you
for the opportunity to speak today uh my
name is Will Walker I live in Hollis
with my 24y old son soon to be 25 uh he
has autism and my wife and I are very
concerned about his future what his
future is going to bring um so I'm here
to support uh hp1 1291 and in particular
uh page one lines 18 and 19 that talk
about um abused by Wright and page three
lines 1 three that talk about increasing
the uh the uh size uh limit to from 750
to 1,000 square F feet um so as my wife
and age and I age you know we really
worry about what's going to happen to
our son uh we want to prepare him for
life without us uh we don't want to all
of a sudden be not present and have him
go through a transition that's going to
be very difficult we have the time we
have the be the ability to plan for his
transition um and also after the meeting
uh about the special committee on uh um
uh studying the housing crisis for
people developmental disabilities that
we have a year a week or two ago um I
have uh compiled a document uh that that
talks about all the common well-known
choices for people with disabilities in
the state as well as all the sources of
funding that people in the uh State have
I'm in the final throws of having
reviews on that done and I'll release it
publicly as soon as that is done and and
give it to you that's helpful thank you
so uh just want to make you aware that
I'm aware of many many different choices
for housing uh the ones we have
considered for our son are purchasing a
home for him and having a enhanced
family care provider or home care
provider live with him um and another is
an Adu on our house okay in a similar
situation uh the the challenge with
something like a home uh for our son
with an enhanced family care provider is
that it's can be brittle and what'll
happen is if the if the care provider is
no longer present we now have our son
who does not he cannot live
independently okay so we have what's the
five minutes going to bring what the two
hours going to bring what's the day
what's the week what's the month going
to bring what's the long-term solution
and so what happens and we've seen this
with families that I know uh this has
happened to them they've purchased a
home for their
son the care provider is no longer
present the son has to now move back and
go through a disruptive change okay so
that was not a viable choice for us an
Adu however provides us the ability to
have some resiliency in this uh system
if if the care provider is no longer
present we're right next door we can
help provide the care we can provide the
continuity of care we can be resilient
and and and provide our son with the
ability to handle this change until we
can and until we can find a new enhanced
family care provider
um the the 750 s feet minimum uh that we
have right now or sorry
maximum I I always struggle with how to
phrase that but that 750 square feet
number is a big challenge because it
really supports what we would call an
in-law apartment where there's a couple
uh living
in a single bedroom in a place in a
situation with my son what we would have
is a need for two bedrooms okay because
people need privacy they need personal
space 750 square feet does not allow
that a th000 square feet would okay so
this would provide my my wife and I the
ability to at our own expense to build
an Adu to provide a a long-term housing
solution for our son um and I I guess
what I'd also potentially add is it's
funny that the 750
number it it seems to imply an addition
uh of square footage to the house right
if you have somebody with a large house
who's now an empty nester um maybe
there's a possibility to divide that
house use existing rooms to build an Adu
out of that and so why do you want to
constrict that to 750 fet as well all
right if I don't I don't know if you
understand what I'm I'm saying here but
that's that's what I'm trying to say so
uh please uh help me help my wife
uh find a long-term solution for my son
by supporting hb1
1291 thank you very much for your
testimony are there any questions Mr
shair representative D Lorenzo thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question you said that you need um your
son he needs that two
bedrooms well what would happen if you
have an enhanced home sorry home care
provider living with somebody you have
two people living there okay but you
know that's a very good question uh
representative uh there are people
people that need uh medical equipment
okay they they have a they have a use
for medical equipment or a therapy room
or or something so they need the
additional square footage as well thank
you representa coni thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you sir for your
testimony do you have um do you have
written testimony of what you just spoke
of I submitted it when we were going to
cover the thing uh two weeks ago okay
thank you looking forward to seeing that
thank you and I've also submitted a
follow on email that points you to a
large number of organizations in the
state that are the subject matter
experts uh for people with disabilities
especially people with developmental
disabilities in the state thank you sir
thank you Mr okay any other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you for your
time is there anybody else that has not
testified on hp1 1291 that would like to
testify seeing none I'm going to close
the public hearing and I thought we'd be
too early on this but it looks like
we're right on the right on time chair
on his estimation of timing yeah that
was great so we're going to be in recess
you
for
again I know I don't have a
gabble
here we go I'm gonna call on you first
on your
bill do you have the amendment
here going well if it's in your
email is it in your email I don't know
ask hey Ben
do we have cop do we have an amendment
number for Scott for the um his bill is
right hope I was hoping that you would
consider that as a possible Amendment to
the sprinkler bill as
well the one that has amendment to HB
blank yeah I that you just passed it
okay it has to do with the um local
building
well um I I'm going to start with 1361
because representative Wallace is
getting his things together um and I
um so let's get started with
1361 um I have a lot of amendments
too so
1361 I have passed around an amendment
number
1035 and I apologized to the committee I
hadn't sent it to you earlier it
literally was drafted 30 minutes ago so
um I emailed them on Monday and they
just got got it to me today so
um this I believe so so to start during
the public hearing I think the committee
indicated that they wanted to um from
what I understand correct me if I'm
wrong lay the hammer down more on
manufactured housing um
I would personally support that but I
think what's better as a committee is
that we rewrite the statute make it more
clear which is what this amendment does
um and then we present it to the house
and we help educate members on what
manufactured housing is because I think
that this is a long-term solution to the
housing crisis is start with
manufactured housing um so this
amendment replaces the bill except for
the effective date I believe and um just
clarifies some language that were issues
at the public hearing so I hope that
you'll at least consider this
representative
Reed thank you uh C do you mind because
I just got back from the restroom can
you walk us through the different pieces
of the amendment that replaces the bill
the so this kind of breaks it up so
there was an amendment that was floating
around during the public hearing which
was
0114 which
was almost the same um I also have Ben
here that's able to explain the
differences between the two but it
basically rewrites the current statute
and
um allow basically says that
municipalities cannot regulate
manufactured housing exclude it
completely from the municipality it has
to provide reasonable zoning in
reasonable and realistic opportunities
for it um but Ben do you mind walking us
thank you Mr chairman Ben Frost from New
Hampshire housing uh we're
addressing uh 135h or
[Music]
135h uh you as the chairman noted you
had seen uh another amendment uh before
114h and there was some questions about
Clarity and so this attempts to address
that um what this does is it takes the
existing statute uh and parses it out in
a way that is uh readable and logical uh
it there's some ambiguity in the the
structure of the current law but what is
proposed here in this amendment uh
clarifies that and says these are the
obligations of the minicipal
relative to manufactured housing so um
what you see on lines um particularly
lines 9 through 19 is really where the
parsing occurs so this is what
municipalities are currently supposed to
do and it just puts it in a format
that's easier to read uh they must allow
manufactured housing on individual Lots
or in manufactured housing parks and in
manufactured housing Park
subdivisions uh manufactured housing
parks are places where the the unit
owner the the occupant owns the unit but
not the land underlying it a
manufactured housing uh subdivision is
where the unit owner also owns the land
under it so it's like a it's like a
subdivision but just especially designed
for manufactured housing Parks or
manufactured housing and I know that uh
Rochester in particular does have a
provision in its zoning ordinance that
deals with manufactured housing
subdivisions um so they they're treating
that properly um lastly you can a
municipality can allow all three if it
wants to but it's obligation is under
one and two betweens line between lines
11 and
um the clarification here and this gets
to representative K's question on the
day of the hearing whenever that was
last month uh in lines 5 through 8 uh
the current
law says manufactur municipalities shall
afford reasonable and realistic
opportunities for the sighting of
manufactured housing and manufactured
housing parks and
subdivisions and that confuses what
follows uh the the the the obligation
language and so what you see here in the
amendment
135h lines 5 through 8 uh clarifies that
by simply referring to what follows B in
and eliminates that confusing language
it doesn't change the substance of the
law it just makes it clear what makes it
easier to
read
um following down lines 20 through 26 uh
is essentially that what's in existing
statutes
um what's different than uh actually
[Music]
through through 30 is existing statute
uh new is section is so paragraph e
starting in line 31 and extending over
to the following page uh through line
two so that's new language but is
essentially an existing obligation of
municipalities to allow for expansion of
of existing parks
language do you mind answering some
questions I'd be happy to answer
questions representative Reed and I'll
I'll note that uh Sarah marant is also
here she's the chief of staff from the
Community Loan
Fund represent readed go ahead thank you
uh thank you for taking my question um
my memory and I was actually trying to
find the bill in my folder and I can't
seem to um is that the original Bill
sought to allow manufactured homes
wherever um stick builts were allowed is
that is that correct and I understand
the the language cleanup but as I read
um this amendment it's a lot less uh I
guess aggressive and the idea is that as
long as a municipality allows
manufactured housing parks and
manufactur
housing uh all right I guess I'm I'm
trying to understand what a town would
have to allow and would they still have
to allow it on private Lots where stick
builts are um if they allow for parks in
their
town okay so a couple of questions there
um uh regarding the first I think the
bill as
introduced is really just it's a bit
confusing uh and it proposed to
eliminate the
um uh
the L part of the language related to
subdivisions uh the manufactured housing
subdivisions and I think that that
actually added confusion to uh to the
law and it also rearranged some of the
languages but I don't think that it
imposed that kind of obligation that
you're suggesting representative Reed
that that they must be allowed um
wherever stick Built Homes are allowed
uh and stick built or modular I mean
single family homes as opposed to
manufactured housing um so I I don't
think that the bill has introduced
changed that
standard the the amendment and I'm
referring again to
1035 uh essentially mirrors the existing
law and repeats the the obligation so
again municipalities must allow
manufactured
housing on individual Lots where single
family homes are allowed
or allow them in parks and subdivisions
that's the obligation they can allow
them in all three situations if they
want to uh but they have to do on
individual Lots or in parks and
subdivisions
Damon thank you thank you for taking my
question so I'm trying to compare the
original Bill the other Amendment and
this
amendment
efficiently and I think overall my
question is it sounds like almost all of
what's in this newest amendment is
already existing law and if I'm correct
about that what are we accomplishing
with
this that's a great question um I I
would say that
wherever you as legislators can impart
Clarity to the law you're making
people's lives better and I think this
does that uh it I will I will confess
I've
been practicing Municipal law uh well
this is this will be my 30th Anniversary
um in new hampsh and I've been a planner
for 40 years um for at least a couple
decades I was misreading the existing
law and and it was only until I really
sat down with it
and oh okay different Bill uh I really
sat down with it and and studied it and
thought about it that I realized I had I
I had seen these these things as
three exclusive options individual plots
Parks subdivisions but it's that parks
and subdivisions that I'd been
misreading and I recognize now if if if
I'd really taken the time to to think
through it I would have seen that so I
figured well if if I'm confused about it
probably other people are confused about
it too and so this does seek to clarify
that um I will point out representative
Damon that uh e starting on lines 30 31
of page one uh is new language the rest
of it is pretty much the existing law uh
it
does
um the existing law in in one place said
um reasonable opportunities and another
another place said realistic
opportunities and in both places it now
says reasonable and realistic so that's
a slight language shifting but with no
think thank you that's helpful and I
certainly do agree that the formatting
is easier to follow and be clear
about however I'm concerned that I
believe our original intent with this
yes I shouldn't be speaking for
representative Alexander but I'm going
to um was
to promote more opportunity for
manufactured housing to be
utilized and I'm I guess I would be
asking do you think this in some way
does that yes it does e uh starting on
line 31 page one does achieve
that and I I would also say that
um many of our colleagues in my opinion
are not as educated on what manufactured
housing looks like and I hope you'd
agree with me on that um and I think
that when we're talking about solutions
to the housing crisis we need to first
start from a point of maybe not
everybody knows everything and I think
if we rewrite the statute to make it
clear as a committee we're helping to
educate not only the public but our
colleagues on um the importance of this
this piece of the puzzle um so I would
say like yes in the in the ideal world I
would love an amendment that would just
like build up manufactured housing
everywhere right like but I think when
we start here I'm an incrementalist and
when we start here and rewrite it and
make it clear then we can go on maybe
next year when there's maybe a rule
change and there's an actual committee
on housing we can kind of work work
towards this goal and move in the right
direction this moves it in the right
direction in my opinion representative
Reed thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question again and I am in
agreement with everything that's been
said I would love to just see a bill
that's like manufactured housing is
allowed wherever you have a lot um my
question is so I and I I hate to like
dig down like this so this says that a a
municipality must provide it
in on individual Lots in most but not
necessarily all land areas in districts
zone for uh residential use use or the
housing parks and subdivisions and I
appreciate the clarification that you're
bringing to to this because I understand
what you what you had always interpreted
was they can allow either Lots or Parks
or subdivisions and what you're saying
no you have to do lots or parks and
subdivisions however when we say in most
but not necessarily all land areas
that's going to be by acreage am I right
not by number number of lots in the town
and um still being incrementalist and
not doing the yeah you just are going to
have to allow manufacturing houses could
we not say in most of the Lots in the
town instead of most of because I could
foresee especially towns that have 20
acre lot minimums them just saying oh
there's a few lots that we're going to
allow a manufactured house on but the
vast majority of lots still would not
allow it and I'm wondering if that would
be something that would be feasible to
do here thank you for that question I I
think and bear in mind this is existing
law and it's been law since the early
80s uh that language is in the current
law and so municipalities have been
dealing with it for uh several
decades um I I think the the term land
areas uh refers to exactly that acreage
not number of lots if the legislature
had intended number of lots it would
have said number of lots it said instead
area and that's that is acreage or
whatever unit of aerial measurement you
want to use um
so most but not necessarily all uh call
it a term of art if you if you want but
it's uh it's certainly something more
than than a
majority uh
it's it it's more than 51% uh most is is
something substantially larger than that
what the exact number is I don't know uh
and it has never been litigated and it's
never been raised really as an issue um
it is the existing law if if you wanted
to put some flesh on those bones I think
that's that might be helpful but uh just
keep in mind that this this has been the
law for U you know 40
years represent mononi thank you Mr
chairman um thank you uh for for the
amendment here
um I sincerely appreciate what you're
trying to do here I am one that has
great familiarity with what we're
talking about here uh and I especially
like that you listen to the committee
and added e in the bottom there and I I
think that's a great step forward and um
I'm in the support of what they've
brought forward here thank you thank you
represent Vell
thank you um I think I have
to uh agree with representative Damon
that I feel like I'm Shuffling the
chairs on the Titanic kind of a thing um
and not actually move like
moving us in a substantially New
Direction that this is just a rewrite
and and so what is what is the um you
know other than Clarity like the the
this I feel like I would like to do more
than that um and
one
way that I ask that the that this
committee consider that is
um the consideration of
that maybe some some meat on the bones
are reasonable and realistic and and
specifying that there shall be um you
know
some
part some undeveloped Lots in the zone
or in this uh what did we call it land
areas uh that that is most of the Town
it needs to actually have some under de
developed lots that
could
uh accommodate these uh additional units
um
obviously any lot couldn't be de be uh
you know leveled and then started over
but that's not really getting to the
point of this committee which is more
housing
um and so I I just kind of throw that
out there as as possibly some meat on
the bones of like saying like hey you
actually it's great that you you know uh
designated your swamp as being able to
uh
allow uh manufactured housing but
there's no Lots on it that are
developable I I understand where you're
coming from and I think maybe one of my
proposals is that we start here as a
bare minimum and we approve this and
then maybe committee members are allowed
to to put in a floor Amendment and if
that passes but I don't want to not do
anything so if we rewrite and then if
you want to put more meat in the bones
like go ahead and introduce some sort of
amendment to add that um but at least
we're moving this in I believe the right
direction that's that's my proposal to
you go ahead representative Reed thank
you Mr chair also I am also in agreement
with representative Damon and yella that
I would also like to see a little bit
more forward movement I appreciate that
here's uh suggestion that that might
come in the form of a floor Amendment
perhaps getting to both what I said in
terms of number of lots and what
representative yella said we could add
on line 11 in individual on individual
Lots in most but not necessarily all
land areas and in no case um less than
75% of undeveloped Lots in the
municipality or something like that um
my question is I thought from our he or
the first the hearing that we had said
down on line 31 uh e that we needed to
add not just the expansion of
manufactured housing Parks but also the
building of new did did in the rewriting
of that did we forget that part or did
we determine that expansion included the
new is that addressed to me thank you Mr
chairman okay um it was
um not inadvertent it was a a conscious
Choice uh to limit the scope of the bill
point go ahead represent
demon
um so one I I do respect the value of
incremental process in getting something
accomplished is far better than
nothing and and patience is not my
middle
name um we sh non mdle
name so maybe there'll be an amendment
forthcoming
that includes creating uh manufactured
housing parts that's just a statement
I'm trying to figure out and and Mr
Frost this is a question for you or
anyone else who can help
me what
distinguishes line five five to
six municipalities shall afford
reasonable and realistic opportunities
you don't need me to read it all what
distinguishes that from line
31 municipalities shall allow realistic
opportunities I mean it's that we're
talking about expansion that is that the
substance of it fif I'm sorry line five
I'm on page one versus line 31 they
sound really not very different to
me admittedly yes the the words are the
same uh but the context is
different uh so in line five the context
is global that is whether you're doing
it on individual Lots or in parks and
subdivisions that's not that's not the
concern it's just you shall globally in
your regulations allow a reasonable and
realistic opportunity for the sighting
of manufactured housing however
configured on line 31 it's with specific
reference to manufactured housing Parks
okay go ahead
um I just want to note that in the
analysis and again correct me if I'm
Excuse me misinterpreting but I think
it's an error in the second
line when it says on individual lots and
in manufactured Parks because it seems
to me
the language on page one is or not and
so that's really quite a different
meaning in that analysis and I confess I
do not prepare the
analyses so we should fix that represent
VI I think uh yes thank you um I think
that the analysis is
actually
um
correct the analysis is correct um and
that is because um it
is
uh e is
not
dependent
on which you choose in A or B it e is
its own at the same level as a and so
you have to even if you chose on
individual if you chose individual lots
and you technically were not choosing
that other one you also now have to
allow
reasonable opportunities of expansion of
existing manufactured
uh uh manufactured housing Park so if
you you know let's say at some time in
the past previously had a manufacturer
Park get approved let's say through a
zba process or something that was not
currently allowed or what whatnot y now
even though you chose option one now you
have to also allow the expansion of that
existing one even though you're not
doing option two right in in in B he's
right and Mr chairman if I may I think
you're both right actually and I'll
point out point out why representative
Kelly you're right the second sentence
does refer to e the first sentence of
the
analysis uh perpetuates the the error of
the two
ands so it's uh the the
obligation um is on individual Lots or
in manufactured housing parks and
obligation go ahead thank you are you
trying to um because I think they're
trying to get at e and in that sentence
are are you implying that maybe we
should add in E that municipalities
should have a reasonable ex realistic
expectation uh opportunities for
expansion of housing parks
and
uh
subdivisions in which case it would be
in line with two if if uh you had a
subdivision and you needed to expand the
subdivision then that would also be be
covered
because they go together as a pair
apparently
right I I was I wasn't meaning to imply
that but I think that's an interesting
idea the I I will point out and and I
think you've already articulated this
clearly representative your Cola e gets
to those things that might be
non-conforming uh uses so someone
established a manufactured housing Park
prior to the adoption of zoning uh so
it's a legally existing non-conforming
use not generally subject to ex spatial
expansion this allows for the spatial
expansion of those otherwise
non-conforming
uses prep coni do you have a question
you thank you um I want to caution on
putting numbers in here in most
Lots
um to two things there are people
sitting around this room that understand
how this will benefit and increase
housing stock there are towns and
individual property owners that will be
terrified of
this small bites is much much better and
I just I I I've sat on zoning boards
I've chaired zoning boards I peer in
front of zoning boards all the time and
the the
misinterpretation of this ordinance is
Broad and trying to get boards to
understand what's here so I think
there's Merit in that um there is
tremendous Merit in manufactured parks
in
e um subdivisions is not not as big an
issue um and for the most part A
subdivision you know if you have a
subdivision and it has manufactured
homes in in it which I have done in the
past um it's not an issue it's it's
having enough land mass to go forward
what I do want to mention is there is so
there are very many properties in your
towns in towns that I serve that were
original subdivisions that already say
in it no manufactured homes no trailers
and now when you start adding up all of
those and then you apply a percentage
you're going to make it very difficult
number one to come to what that number
is but also you may be forcing more
units that you don't want so crawl on
this one it's it's and I'll save it for
executive session I I I think you have
you representative Reed thank you once
again so just to recap what this bill is
actually doing because I know that I had
some initial confusion as did I think
others I would just like to kind of
paraphrase it so Roman numeral one we
have a through E A says globally you
have to provide reasonable and realistic
which is the part we're adding uh
opportunities for manufactured housing
in general b a town has to either allow
it on most of the acreage for individual
residential units or in parks
and subdivisions or all
three
c um for the Lots you can't have any
additional restrictions that you don't
have on a regular
Home D if you chose the parks and and
subdivisions or the parks anyway um
realistic and reasonable opportunities
for their development and then e if you
have
existing uh Parks you you have to allow
for reasonable and realistic
opportunities for their
expansion so this gives I I I guess
that's so Mr Frost thank you that was a
question I think yeah this I mean this
still allows municipalities a lot of
discretion on what they're going to do
but it just makes it clear that
something like they need to do something
in there so and there's a lot of options
here on the table so it's a menu It's A
nudge and I think a lot of us share the
idea that um that we would like to do a
little bit more than a nudge but I will
defer to the rest of the committee how
much more if any okay representative
Damon thank you I'm hoping to move on in
a little bit too because we need we have
other
bills
so perhaps there is some legal
definition that I'm unaware of of what
the meaning of reasonable is excuse me
I'm particularly looking at that on line
30 although it's in here more than once
what so what my then teenage daughters
thought was reason reasonable was not
reasonable understood um and I I have
had a teenage daughter myself
um this is a term uh that again comes
from the existing Statute in one place
it said reasonable in another place it
said realistic we've merged them and
that the merger of those two to to read
reasonable and realistic uh really is
straight out of the workforce housing
uh so the same
language uh reasonable and realistic
opportunities uh occurs in the workforce
housing law uh it is ambiguous or not
perfectly clear there as well and that
was done intentionally so to give
municipalities in the words of that
statute maximum feasible
flexibility so uh consistent with
representative M's admonition not to put
in numbers um give municipalities the
flexibility to figure out how to do it
in a way that suits them locally uh the
language here most of land areas is
pretty clear clear enough to give good
guidance to municipalities about what
do that's helpful it sounds like you're
saying that when you put reasonable and
realistic together that is stronger
alone I'm not sure that it's stronger um
but it it eliminates the need to ask
what's the difference between reasonable
and what's the difference between
reasonable and realistic where they
occurred in different places here it's a
single phrase mirroring the workforce
housing law so therefore might we not
want to do that in line 30 have it say
shall be reasonable and realistic as it
does in line five indeed yes you could
you so go ahead represent
Reed uh thank you once again um would it
not be true that adding on line 11 on
individual Lots in most but not
necessarily all land areas and in no
case in most Lots would also not
number
yes okay so my question of the committee
is the committee
comfortable executing this this
afternoon or or are there members of the
committee that would like to work on
language I and I think represent mconie
I think there's a few of us that are
comfortable executing it um this
afternoon but if if I'll defer to the
rest of the
committee thank thank you Ben I mean I
think that one simple thing if the
committee is is is amendable like the
the language on
[Music]
um of and lots throughout 9 through n
where it says land areas just a say and
lots and then on line 30 say and
realistic as was just mentioned uh if we
could get that drafted before the the um
any this is like you know A Bridge Too
Far maybe maybe it is with uh with some
members if if it is then I will not try
and get one but I can repres makoni
thank you if uh if as a separate
Amendment if it can be brought in before
i' be happy to consider it okay so I'm
going to task representative yella to
run down to OS real
quick please okay so next I'm going to
call on represent ative Wallace to
discuss um House Bill 1215 relative to
subdivision
regulations no it's a work session so
say okay uh thank you Mr chairman the
amendment to uh House Bill
1215 uh addresses a couple of items that
were brought up by the uh uh code
enforcement and the uh fire inspector
the in the legislative intent that we
had with this
um was such that once the subdivision is
approved those regulations and terms in
uh pursuant to that particular
subdivision remain in place and there
was some confusion on whether or not the
building codes would be frozen in time
so to speak at that same time that's not
the intent this uh Amendment fixes that
ambiguity to the extent that uh the
building and fire codes would be current
uh as of the date of issuance of the
building uh permit so for example
hypothetically speaking the three of us
get together we develop a piece of
property we start construction and F we
get our approvals on the subdivision say
in 2024 those apply we start pulling out
building permits 5 years hence whatever
building codes are in existence and fire
codes five years from now are the codes
that would be applicable to the the
particular subdivision and then uh Ben
Frost also uh made a couple of tweaks to
the to the 10 and
fiveyear uh pause on the uh the code
changes so so that's what the amendment
does and that's very much in uh concert
with the original intent of this
particular Bill and uh that's that's it
in essence thank you representative
Wallace um I have a question for um Bill
mcken and um Fire Marshall tum me is
this language acceptable and address
your
concerns feel free yeah come on up it's
so thank you chairman Alexander members
of the committee Bill McKinny with en
Hampshire building officials Association
uh relative to the Amendments and yes it
addresses is our most significant
concerns is that the building in fire
codes would still move forward and we'd
be bu building to the most up-to-date
codes that we can I do have a question
of on number two and I think it's more
for clarification for my part um amend
34 I
believe and the language is is it the
building code Board of appeal shall hear
and decide appeals of orders decisions
or determinations made by the building
official or Fire official relative to
the application and interpretation of
local amendments to the state building
code is it the intent
to now bypass the local board of appeals
if one is in effect to and limit them to
only the local amendments and then you'd
go you'd bypass and immediately go to
the building code review board for
appeals of anything involving the state
Cod Ben would you like to answer that
since you were heavily involved in the
you I never thought I would have the
opportunity to sit together with Phil
mckenny this it's a very special
committee wonderful
day um the the intent is to um as Mr
McKinny noted is to limit the
appeals uh that are heard by the local
building code board of appeals which is
usually in most communities the Zoning
Board of adjustment uh by Statute if you
don't have a separate building code
board of appeals then it it is the
Zoning Board of adjustment that serves
as the bcba and they they are a body
that does not have experience in
building codes um
so the the objective here is to uh limit
their review to those situations where
the municipality has made local
amendments to the building code or to
the fire code uh everything else uh
would go straight to the State Building
Code review
board
okay does that satisfy uh you folks it
does it helps to exp clarify that for me
uh you know it's uh
um my one concern with that is you know
not knowing the exact number of appeals
around the state you know would we be
overly burdensome to the um State build
and code review board with number of
appeals going immediately to them and
that possibly we we could look at um if
you're willing is you know maybe some
language in there and in the absence of
a local building code board of appeals
then it immediately goes to the state
because I agree removing the Z Boards
out of the appeals process on building
sense okay all right are there any other
or okay thank you very much um Fire
add
thank you Sean to me you State Fire for
the record um I'm good with what they
said the only quick uh if we're clean
things up the state fire code is 155a
and the state uh State Building Code is
155a State Fire code would be3 that's
all just for clarity since we're making
a few minor changes but I uh I'm good
with the rest you on number two okay on
the second page um where it's
down that should be 153 A1 is the state
fire code would be 153 uh 1531 is where
the definition of the state fire code
is and then the same thing would happen
three okay are we so let me ask the
committee are we comfortable voting on
this bill this afternoon if
representative Wallace can get a couple
quick fixes done to this
bill I see NOS thank you very
much it's a lot easier than I thought
um HB 1065 I'm going to call on
representative Damon um if you can chat
a little bit about um possible
amendments that you have to your bill
and I also have an amendment myself that
entertain
so from what I heard at the
um before you start from what I heard of
the public hearing is that um I believe
there's still merit to this bill because
I think that the rule change that was
happening in the Senate was just
regarding existing structures and not
new structures being being built so I
think by and large this would cover new
and existing is that correct
representative
Damon um you are correct about the
Senate bill um however this is also
existing buildings it's not new
construction okay I mean it's not new
from the ground up construction it could
be new in the sense of an old home being
reconfigured into four Apartments okay
so um
there are two proposed amendments and I
have to run upstairs and get the second
one because we just did it but you have
just received Amendment
1034 um and this is the language that
was actually recommended by Mr Frost uh
in our prior discussion to essentially
make it clearer um it does not change
the meaning of the bill I do not
believe
um it puts in the phrase
notwithstanding any other provision of
law to the
contrary
um and let me just refresh my memory
here nothing else is changed that's to
address potential conflicts in other
parts of the statute correct okay which
is which is something that was a concern
of the Fire Marshall okay could be
concern okay um and the whoops the one
that I will run up in get moment
momentarily
uh
sorry it's not the right one can you I'm
just gonna go get yeah we're gonna um be
minutes
oh
to
all right we are back um we're back
representative Damon can you please
explain the other Amendment thank you Mr
chair let's try this again so the newly
passed out Amendment Amendment
1039 should actually I hope replace the
first amendment I gave you um Roman
number
three is same in both um and makes the
change of the notwithstanding any other
provision of the law to the contrary
Roman number Roman number
four adds lines 18 to 20 to the existing
statute So currently statutes says that
counties towns cities and Village
districts
cannot make regulations that are less
stringent than the state fire code this
is suggesting that they may also not
make them more
stringent this all came out of the
public hearing
recommendations that's what I have I I
think this makes a lot of sense and I
think that was one of the
recommendations is that municipalities
are able to make them more stringent so
if we um trust the fire code on the on
the state level I'm I'm comfortable with
this
amendment anyone
else represent mcon thank you uh thank
you both but Mr chairman um are we going
to discuss a further amendment to this
construction I'm going to leave that up
sponsor
so two things directing this to the
experts in the audience
particularly uh Fire Marshall to me one
is the existing Amendment acceptable to
processed thank you Sean Tumi for the
record against St far Marshall uh my I
don't love it I know um obvious viously
but uh I guess it leaves me with a
couple of questions um especially when
we deal with mixed use buildings still
um so if we had four Apartments upstairs
from a commercial use
um are we saying now that that building
can't require a sprinkler system when it
would be a potential solution
for um separations and things like that
that's I think that's why I was hoping
that we
could uh well either a lot of the
Amendments on the building of fire codes
which are proceeding through or
um just simply say like the compliance
with the state fire code I guess that's
my concern is that it this really ties
the hands on no sprinklers with up to
four families I think and that the
sprinkler systems are used in some cases
especially in mixus as commercial
residential or when we have as we talked
about when there um very unique
circumstances that on especially on
egress and things like that that if we
say no sprinklers at all I think it's
going to it's going to make it harder
for us to apply the code in some of
these cases I will say I
fully I fully support where we're at as
far as um there are certain cases where
there are four you know four unit
apartment buildings that existing that
no sprinkles I'm okay with that um as
long as it meets the existing chapters
for the Life Safety
Code
so if I may yep line six says in a
structure used only for residential
purposes how does that not address mixed
juice
buildings uh so that one says for
detached one and two family dwellings
only I
think I think that L five and six are
kind of tied together so it doesn't
right okay representative
verudi thank you Mr chairman
uh Mr fire now if you had a mix use
building wouldn't
the restrictor of the requirements go to
a commercial and and that would take
precedence over say this because it's
not just residential would you have to
live by the
commercial um ordinance where we're in
commercial as soon as we
essentially pass the one and two family
dwelling kind of thing spot so but a far
it but it's not an apartment say it's a
store or a some kind of shop now it's
not a residential
use correct but it's it's still it's
still saying building it's sprinkler
system shall not in line eight sprinkler
system shall not be required in existing
buildings intended for maybe so so only
for similar to the line above so there
State Fire code ass will shall not
require fire Express or sprinkle systems
in new one or two family dwellings using
or or
existing buildings up to no more than
four dwelling units used only for
residential purposes is that something
to think about just I'm thinking out
loud here which is dangerous the key is
right yeah so I I was just thinking a
lot which is always a little dangerous
here right but the state fire code and
Associated rules should not require fire
Express and sprinkle systems and detach
one or two family
dwellings dwelling units and a structure
used only for residential purposes if we
add in there uh after or two family
dwellings two dwelling units unless we
just go up to that's new so I think we
need to add a a comma after the two
family dwelling units comma or
uh where is it existing buildings
intended for no more than four dwelling
units yeah
right so it's just the way the language
was written instead of saying or two
family dwelling units you cross that out
and write dwelling units meant for four
units or less right yeah we're existing
I mean I heard the new language in there
I'm I'm really opposed to the new idea
but um I I I get it for the existing but
go
ahead so be new representative Damon
Muki I think I'm
confused
um so I think I heard you say two
different things probably did so sorry
no no it's fine it's a work session so
one I do agree that we need to fix the
language I'm I was not trying to make
this be for mixed use buildings so I
think we'll just sort out that language
to make sure that we amend the amendment
revise the amendment to do that but the
second part of what you just
said what is the part that you are
opposed
to new new four
units okay I thought you were saying new
language referring to the second half of
the
amendment okay um so I let me try this
again I think I I think I wrote a you if
I may so Starry in line five the state
fire code and Associated rule shall not
require fire suppression or sprinkler
systems and detached one or two family
dwelling
units and this is where it be or
existing buildings for no more than four
purposes bam representing a coni yeah
tot that's fine so now if I if I could
our conversation was a lot of vacant
commercial buildings that are out there
and I agree that mixed residential has
its own hazards and need to be addressed
but it's it's putting those buildings
into uh a residential way and if it's no
more than four units and it can meet
other compliance codes that makes the
them happy I that I think that is uh
fantastic I may ask my friend Ben behind
me because I think he suggested the
notwithstanding any other provision but
I don't know if we put that in front of
all of this or not
I'm I don't know this is the the
amendment says notwithstanding right
after your proposed yeah I don't I don't
my suggestion
is I'm wondering if we just get rid of
all the rest of that so
put notwithstanding other provision of
the law to the contrary comma and then
go to line five the state fire code and
Associate rules I have it drafted if you
want to see it but I don't I don't think
you need the if we do what we said
before you don't need the um if
compliance with State Fire code
including not limit to fire barriers
that's already in the code like I I
think that that's already there and we
can talk about it um means of Escape
windows and monitored fire alarm like I
don't think this says monitored fire
alarm systems monitored fire alarm
systems aren't required for except for
bigger buildings so if you're asking to
put them in I'm good with that but
that's adding a cost for commercial fire
alarm so being so I think if you just
stop it at the top that first five and
six with a little I can give this to you
represent Damon
um I would just cut seven through 11 and
let the code be the code on that side of
it so that we're
not 100 itself I just don't have I just
my question added question was just do
we need the notwithstanding that's all
lawyer representative D Lorenzo then
representative yell okay thank you Mr
here and thank you for taking my
question so um following up on the
praise
um monitored fire alarm systems what are
we talking about when we say monitored
fire alarm systems so it would be the
like the systems that in this building
basically the horn strobes the detectors
and all that so typically a a small
a small residential like would be like
you home where I hope you have a smok
and carbon monoxide in each level of
your home and you have a smoke alarm in
your bedroom and that's what but the way
this is written monitored firearm system
would require a a syst a commercial
system likes in this building that
reports out offsite and things like that
which for a small residential that's
typically not required so so the new
amended language would scratch that out
so that we wouldn't have that concern in
there um represent Vella
thank you um just
to kind
of see if I'm on on the same page um
you're thinking from line five to 7
replaced with not withstanding any other
PR provision of law to the contrary the
state fire code and Associated rules
shall not require fire suppression or
sprinkler systems in detach one or two
family dwelling units or existing
building uh
for use no uh for no more than four
dwelling units um intended solely for
residential use intended solely for res
uh or in a structure used only for
residential use correct okay okay so
um that seems okay so I'm going to put
representative Damon in charge of that
um I'm okay with that language is there
anybody that's not okay with that
keep uh yes we're going to keep Roman
numeral four and it's going to say at
the end however counties cities towns
Village districts shall not adopt rules
regulations ordinances that are more
stringent than the state fire code
relative to residential sprinkler
systems which is specific to residential
which was my question earlier so that's
fine with you I'm okay with that I had a
phone call this week last week asking me
why do we make it so hard to put systems
in from someone that wanted to put it in
so love it let's make it easier
represent Kella um I'm just wondering
about this line um 18 to 20 if
we
um about the the possibility of possibly
saying
that
we if we're already going to get an
amendment uh to this however uh that we
include in addition to relative uh to
residential sprinker systems we say um
or
occupancy
uh residential residential occupancy
because yeah I I don't want to I don't
want to add that language it's G to
muddy it up a little bit I'd rather just
keep it to what we I understand I
understand you want to take a bigger
bite of the Apple but I personally think
that we've gotten to a point where the
Fire Marshall is not openly opposed to
this bill hopefully not um so I'd
consider that a win and then where also
making it easier for people to build
more units inside their existing
buildings all right I don't you're a
member of this Committee just like me
but that's that's what I would
say represent
makoni um thank you and I I guess I'd
direct this to uh Fire Marshall Tumi um
line 13 first four
words if um I I see him is unnecessary
and I believe the governor has directed
language to remove that uh and I believe
it's referring to if he or she findes
which I think is referring to the State
Fire Marshal if you were sitting there
as a woman I believe that woman would
still be the fire
marshal I would ask that you strike that
language so I believe the governor's
already instructed uh departments to do
that and it's no disrespect to the other
it's just not
necessary so you would so in the
amendment representative Damon you would
strike here she
finds
that stsh may exemp a building structure
equipment from such
rules
exemption yes so not just that you have
to go yeah you have to go all the way so
the the for the words would be he or she
finds that strike
that I will say that OS has been
directed to always add she wherever
there's a he in existing statute so I
don't know what the governor's
instruction is the governor came out
War directing that we not necessary
biry noer associated with that term
representa Representative no I do
understand that the title has no gender
I It's just sometimes pronouns have to
be used in a sentence and then and then
you always have to include
those okay so um I
see correct me if I'm wrong I see us
being able to exact 1065 11
13 I'm looking at this sheet right here
yep
two she's here for the um duplex bill in
the parking bill right 1399
1400 I'm going I'm going to
yeah I don't think we can get the duplex
done but definitely parking we'll see
um all depends on OS too I might I might
show up here one and recess this to 1:30
the executive session to give OS more
time um but so we're gon to
1291 okay and then we're going to right
now we're going to bring
up 1399 and and 1400 so um is there
anybody from the committee that
disagrees with me on on at least that
bills we haven't talked about 1168
yet we can we quickly talk about 1168
since I haven't Amendment for it and
before we move on to all right um we're
having I'm going to break at 12:30
yep okay so I'm gonna call I'll do 11
168 briefly if possible very briefly go
ahead there is before you and now I will
have to find it in my list of any papers
prepared ah with the assistance of nhcd
and it's still a study committee the
only thing it does is it adds um a
substantial list of uh organizations
that the study committee would solicit
testimony or solicit input from so the
New Hampshire count these are all the
organizations we heard testimony from
New Hampshire Council on developmental
disabilities able and H Institute on
disability Etc and it also adds our
committee as one of the entities that
would be reported to
at the end of the study committee and I
think that um understanding that we are
a special committee now we will still be
in existence technically as of November
1st I did look into changing the date of
the reporting date it is in statute that
we H that study committees legislative
study committees have to report November
1st so I couldn't change that um but uh
and I also required a minimum of six
meetings for the study committee because
I thought they needed to U be sure to
take it serious iously so that is the
amendment before you um and the prime
amendment any comments on this amendment
or the bill representative yokal I mean
I'm not gonna go into the exec session
now but
um I still believe that um
even wasting the time I of of crossing
over to the Senate and waiting for the
governor to sign it and then 40 45 day
um 45 days after being signed or being
effective to being unnecessary
delays that this that just to choose
another four
representatives from the house to make
another committee
that is is a part of
housing I think that it's unnecessary
that we could form a
subcommittee within this committee and
even maybe a joint committee with
another committee um a joint
subcommittee with another committee and
start hearings next week and have them
every week until um people uh have feel
like they've been heard and we all the
issues are addressed I don't um so I
think that actually passing the
bill takes longer and gives less
opportunity and it has to be reported
out by November 1st where we could have
hearings until whenever we wanted um and
report whenever we want I I feel like
it's constraining it's it's delaying the
issue for some matter of time so I just
don't understand why it would be um
okay so that's more of a comment for the
exec session I guess I'm wondering if
you have any edits to the amendment that
was proposed I think that the amendment
is very helpful as far as like if this
committee wanted to you know start
scheduling the stuff that that is listed
in these in these
uh uh these things because that's one of
the things that I was asking for kind of
in the in the hearing was that these
these groups that we need to listen to
um be identified that this is this
achieves that goal but okay is the
committee ready to exec the
bill I see yes okay we're going to move
on to um hp400 I'm going to call on
representative MC Williams to come up I
believe she has an amendment to that um
and then hopefully
if we might need to
uh move
into we might need to wait to Z your
other
bill but let's uh let's do
1400 thank you very much chair Alexander
uh you should all have Amendment to
hb400 the number is 2024
853h pass it out to everybody let me
know if you don't have one I've got
extra
um so we've already had the hearing on
this uh this is that the one you emailed
out I emailed two out so this one went
out probably a week and a half ago this
is a really simple parking Amendment um
just to clean up the language about one
parking space per unit I sent one last
night as well related to um the duplex
bill but I don't know if we're going to
parking good okay all right so um what
we heard in the in the hearing and part
of the discussion I had with you
wonderful folks on the committee um is
that it was a little confusing to use
the words minimum and maximum when
talking about Municipal parking
requirements and so this bill has been
cleaned up to remove either of those
words um so on lines 1011 and 12 uh
really we're talking about requirements
so a municipality shall not require more
than one residential parking space per
unit to remove the words minimum and
maximum because that got a little
confusing um so that was the cleanup on
this amendment and I'm happy to answer
questions or join in the discussion or
you know any comments on this any
questions for the the sponsor of this
amendment I think it clears up the
language go ahead represent Reed thank
you and thank you representative and I
appreciate the bill and the cleanup um I
just remember that we had some
conversation around um a community will
consider off premise parking options in
their requ requirements so um was was
that intentionally not put into the
amendment um I think you're confusing
this bill with a different one the off
premise parking yeah was that was part
of your
Adu sorry oh okay I may have been
silently had the thought that we should
include it in this one as well thank
you okay the committee ready to exec
this
bill okay all right so we're going to um
brief
I don't I want to give it the time it
deserves so um I'm gonna hold off we
have an exact notice for next Friday as
well so I'm gonna hold off and if
there's something that comes up during
the exec session on other bills um we'll
go from there okay represent chairman
could could we at least share the
amendment that yes it Representatives
working on it was emailed to the
committee right and you have copies yes
you have physical copies of amendment to
HB 1399 um it's
20241 031 you all have those p passed
out I sent them out last night as well
via email um so this is the latest
working version and I
don't well I'm not going to say never
but I would be happy to respond to
emails or to chat or phone calls or
texts or anything between now and next
Friday regarding this iteration of the
amendment to 1399 it gives us another
week to have dialogue so by all means I
would be happy to do some homework
assignments on this if you have anything
between now and next Friday thank you
okay
all right all right so the committee's
in recess until 1 o'clock hopefully that
time be back at 1 o'clock feel free to
okay
good afternoon welcome to special
committee on housing at this point we're
waiting for committee members to get
back so I'm opening the executive
session on pending bills but I'm going
to recess the executive session until
you
good afternoon we're just waiting for a
shortly
okay welcome back so we're going to
start our executive session um I'm going
to first call on I'm going to open up
the executive session
on House Bill
1361 and I will
motion I believe you have an amendment
to that correct oh okay yes thank you uh
would you like can you pass the
amendment around to us supposed to thank
you Mr chair um
I move uh ought to pass as amended as
amended point of order you have to move
a to pass have that seconded and then
move the amendment yeah I mean it is
true even though my committee doesn't do
that but got okay I
agree okay all right go ahead and move I
second the ought to pass motion okay so
moved by J representative yella seconded
by representative Reed ought to pass and
I I move uh Amendment
d104 I second seconded by representative
Damon um would you like to speak to your
Amendment sure as as discussed earlier
this is the uh essent the exact same
Amendment um that was created by
representative uh Alexander earlier
today with the notable changes on lines
11 um at the end saying and lots lines
14 saying and lots and lines 17 saying
and lots and
on lines 30 of the uh Bill saying and
realistic and those are the
changes from the prior Amendment okay
other other comments on this bill EXC
representative Gib Mr chair um I
couldn't hear which Bill are we on 1361
thank
you represent coni uh thank you Mr
chairman uh I'm satisfied with the
Amendments and we'll be voting in favor
point anyone else representative yella I
mean I think that the well speaking to
the amendment even though the amendment
is the bill as a whole um I think that
the
I still have the concerns about like I
feel like this is a little bit of a baby
step but I think that the discussion
that we heard before about making it
clear that there is um you know
reasonable and realistic opportunities
of expansion of manufactured housing
Parks I didn't include the the
subdivision thing on on the second page
as you as you uh no just
because I'm not sure that how
relevant expansion of
existing subdivisions is um I'm not sure
how often that like how many cases that
actually would cover um you know
assuming that you have lots around you
um that you could add and generally
subdivisions have you know like a street
or something that you're like unlikely
to just like drive through into a new
lot or something like that so just I
think that it wasn't completely uh
necessary and so in in the spirit of
less is more
um I think that this is is less as as of
of bill that I could support as far as
um just cleaning up some language and
maybe some minor uh
expansion um kind of in line with what
representative Alexander Ander said uh
earlier um so even without a further
amendment of you know specifying how
that these Lots need to be you know un
developed already and stuff like that I
think that this is is I would obviously
prefer those types of things but um I
think that this is okay I would be okay
with passing this just as is and and
don't need further amendment to vote for
it on the floor so okay representative
read thank you Mr chair uh as a member
of the this little bigger bite of the
Apple caucus that we have going on here
I agree with everything representative
yela said and uh am still okay with us
moving this forward as is to get what we
it okay yeah and I agree and and and I
think that we need to message better
with other legislators on what
manufactured housing looks like and I
think this is a good step in that
direction um so I hope that you'll
explain this to members but um I think
this is a good rewrite and makes it
clear about what we're looking for as a
state representative
yella um I guess I just have a question
as far as
um the intent of the the chair in that
you seem to be trying to have this be a
messaging tool in which case you may not
want something like this to go on
consent because you actually want to
talk about it on the floor um as a
messaging tool kind of a thing um it
could be a messaging tool and it can
still go on consent okay I I just wanted
to I love that's a good place for it to
be yes okay any other comments represent
Damon I just want to follow up on that
concept of messaging to real quick
explore how we can facilitate that more
broadly than in individual conversations
which by nature take time and can we do
an infomercial in mailboxes I have um
the chair has an idea in the works and
I'll share it with you offline
great representative Reed I don't know
if the idea in the works has anything to
do with this but at bare minimum I think
that our committee could release a press
release regarding this and perhaps like
maybe all the bills that we pass
yep okay just one more visuals because
people's image of manufactured housing
is not up to date in many cases it's
part of part of my mission
representative dorenzo thank you Mr
chair I I'm wondering if we could do PR
to kick back knock back the stigma about
manufactured housing and
um that's things mobile homes yeah yes
okay thank
you yeah that's doesn't okay we're gonna
we're all gonna so is a show of hands
amendment okay okay all those in favor
of amendment number 1040 please raise
your
hand those
opposed okay it was a nine to zero
representative Gibbs wasn't in the room
oh all right so that Amendment passes
now I'll entertain and is any more
discussion on
this Mo a to pass is amended motion
uh for a to pass as amended okay any
discussion okay CL just go ahead I don't
want anybody to fall out of their chair
but I think this is a great great Bill
and I'm happy to support it this was the
type of solution I was looking for when
I asked to get on this committee so I
right all right will the put that on
consent will the clerk call the role we
haven't voted on it yet okay can
everybody relax can the clerk call the
role please yes on the question of ought
to pass as amended uh Vice chairman
barudi
yes representative mcon I representative
Walsh yes clerk votes yes representative
yela yes representative D Lorenzo
representative Reed yes representative
Gibbs yes representative
hope amen yes excuse me representative D
my
apologies chairman Alexander yes 10 Z
love no objections to consent move yeah
yes I love consent
okay so this was my hope all along that
we could come up with some small steps
to move in the right direction so great
job um the next bill I'm going to call
up are we are we all set with amendments
okay um I'm going to open up the
executive session on HB
1168 oh I'm sorry representative yella
can you write the report for
1361 or would you like me
it
okay okay um so now I'd like to open up
the executive session on hb1 68 is there
a motion on this bill I move out to
second sorry the amendment here Mr
chairman the am the amendment was
already
today it is the only amendment on
1168 and I am looking for it right
now
927 amendment number
0927 H they all end in
H we on the same page we need a second
for OT yeah I moved it and second so
moved by representative Reed second by
representative Damon would you like to
speak to your motion I would like to
move amendment number
0927 okay moved and seconded go ahead
and now I will speak to my Amendment um
as previously discussed in work session
this amendment simply adds to the study
committee a list of entities most of
which we had heard directly from um
during the hearing um entities that
would be solicited information from by
the study committee and ads our
particular in in kind of in response to
representative yoel's uh comments from
the hearing uh as our particular
committee as a as an that would be
reported to by the study committee being
that we would be likely the ones to deal
with any proposed
it any other comments on HB
1168 I'm going to say for for me
personally I I think that um this this
committee was created to deal with
finding Solutions the housing crisis I
was personally shocked by how many
people came in to for a public hearing
on a study committee bill um I think the
bill although I'm hesitant to create
study committees I think the bill um
would would at least appease those
members that want to be heard more and
and the in the representatives that want
to serve on that committee specifically
give them the opportunity to study it so
I'm comfortable with
it any other comments Mr repres Lorenzo
I think um looking at how many people
showed up for the hearing and how many
people testified um there is a great
great great need for this type of
Housing and I hope that we can actually
do it with all deliberate speed thank
you represent mononi uh thank you Mr
chairman I
um I have the pleasure of serving on
several
commissions and the issue always which
the issue was brought up by represent o
Kella is that it takes so long to go
through the process and by the time
you're reporting it's impossible to have
meetings so if you're I I agreed with
representative Kella that keep it as a
work group but if if the commit if we
want to pass this I would hope that you
would uh you would then permit this
other this group ad hoc or whatever to
start right away and start holding
hearings until you get a formal
committee otherwise it will will not be
enough time for all these people to be
okay representative Reed I just wanted
to agree that um if we can do this uh
informally or or through our rules or
internal processes to start the process
before this is enacted I do think
considering how many people showed up
and the the intricacies and depth of the
problems that exist that we should
guarantee this committee through statute
but having said that if we can start
getting the ball rolling as soon as
possible um and just add to that then I
would be wholeheartedly supportive of
that okay representative
Damon thank you so to that end the bill
text says that it takes effect on
passage is there process by which we
could expedite the
passage um there's another whole body in
the process
um that so we we can get it on the
calendar
as as early as
mid 22nd I believe 22nd of March 21st of
March um but after that it's out of our
hands once it goes over the other body
ask the the chair of this body in this
on the other side of the wall um to uh
fast track
it
okay all right is the show hands for the
amendment okay can you repeat the
amendment number representative Reed
amendment number
0927 okay all those in favor of
amendment number 0927 please raise your
hand those opposed we're unanimous
awesome is there any more discussion on
this represent
viella thank you um I'm still going to
vote in opposition to this bill as
amended um I believe that the mo proper
motion is interim study and then we will
produce a moot uh the report in November
when we get when we completed the
interim study part and um the then we
will be able to start this right away
and we can have and we could do this as
a subcommittee um task with that interim
study process and it could be uh we can
invite you know members from DHHS or or
um Edna and and uh you know start on
this work and have it go as long as
needed instead of trying to finagle you
know a senator to show up and and
uh so I think that that the it's just
the improper motion and so I'm going to
be opposing the ought to pass but I
think that it's obviously an a needed
thing to look into but I don't think
that for new Representatives
task with relatively the same task that
we are here I'm not trying to pass the
buck to other Representatives I I'm I'm
on it I'm in this for the Long Haul and
so I'm willing to put in the time and
effort so representative Reed thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative I
appreciate your your Viewpoint and I I
think the fact that you pointed out that
we could be doing more work as a
committee um in other modes rather than
just this formal study committee is well
taken uh I am a little bit dismayed at a
motion or a proposed motion to interim
study a study committee but having said
that without the interim study my
understanding is the chair can produce
or on his is at his discretion to create
a uh a work group and can invite perhaps
members of the disability caucus from
the house to that work group and perhaps
we invite Senate members as well but
they don't have to be present in order
for us to proceed with that work
so um I think that we can do this in a
two-pronged approach and still guarantee
a an official study committee to all of
the many people who came out to testify
to us while still helping support that
um through our own work
group representative Walsh
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair uh I also
understand Representatives
representative yoko's point and it's
unfortunate that the time limit uh on
the study committee or commission uh
will be so short but this could I I'm
going to support OTP on this bill
because this committee was set up to
address the housing crisis in general
and I think that um uh a separate focus
on the needs of people with disabilities
value represent Lorenzo um a dose of
reality we all we all have to recognize
that this is an election year we're
going to be pretty darn busy between uh
June and November so does that to
consider as well thank
you representative Reed um I forgot to
mention a piece of the amendment and it
does mandate and I I did the math on
after this would be theoretically signed
in June to the reporting deadline in
November it does mandate at least at
least at a minimum of six meetings of
this study committee which would average
out one every two weeks so we are in
this amendment insisting that they do
that work whereas an unofficial process
up okay if there's no more discussion um
see none Clark will call the rooll on
the uh motion of ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 6 uh
1168 Vice chairman barudi yes
representative makoni I representative
Walsh yes yes CL clerk votes yes
representative
yella no representative D Lorenzo yes
representative Reed yes representative
Gibbs yes representative Damon yes
chairman Alexander
Yes 91 motion passes move consent is
there objection to this going on
consent seeing seeing no objection this
consent okay next up I'd like to move
to right are we still waiting on we're
still waiting on amendments for two of
our bills I just want to check with
Damon
okay okay the next I'd like to move to
hb400 so I'll open up the executive
session
hp400 relative to maximum number of
residents parking
spaces I move out to pass
okay is there an amendment is there a
yella would you like to move an
amendment to I would like to move
0853 okay and that's been seconded as
well okay would you like to speak to
your motion uh yes I think it is very
important that we ensure that towns do
not
um restrict de facto restrict um kind of
in a bad faith way restrict the uh
building of new housing in our terrible
housing crisis currently by requiring uh
on the municipal level uh more parking
spaces than needed this would set that
standard at no more than one per unit um
the amendment I I guess I was speaking
on the bill but the amendment um
clarifies what was confusing language
because it said maximum but minimum but
it's you know is it the state requiring
a maximum of no more than a minimum of
so instead of getting into that what
does maximum minimum mean it says simply
shall not require more than one
residential parking space per unit it
clarifies the original
discussion yeah this I believe your
representative yella seconded both
motions we on the amendment we're on the
amendment
yes representative
Damon so I'm just noting that the
effective date of the amendment is
different from the effective date of the
original it's
later sry you you are correct yes I am
sad to see that um it my understanding
is January 1 of the following year is
the procedure actually required by
Statute for any legislation that creates
a new criminal code like a new crime it
shouldn't it's not appropriate to be on
this amendment having said that I'm not
sure that six months is going to make a
big difference in the world of the the
towns yeah it's got to do with
publishing of the zoning ordinances and
adjust any
comments represent Broody thank you Mr
chairman um
being from Manchester there's a lot of
units in Manchester and some buildings
don't even have one parking space per
unit so um the cities can get around it
I was a president of a condo association
where we had one parking space per unit
and there was 36 units in the building
and we only had four parking spaces
designed for uh visitors out of 36 units
so parking and residential are is um
people find a way to do it um you get
restrictions on parking more in the
commercial and like the restaurants and
things they you know designated a lot of
parking but residential units I don't
adequate representative walson yeah
thanks Mr chair um and I do agree with
what this this bill is trying to do I
agree that the municipality shouldn't be
using parking as a way to uh deter
development but it I just I I have a
fear of some of the problems that of one
size fits all like this can create in my
time on the planning board we had
countless um people coming in that lived
in apartment buildings uh condos tow
houses that we were giving two parking
spaces and they were still clamoring for
more uh particularly in the holiday
periods and visitors I mean there was no
place for anybody to park other than
than taking somebody else's parking
place which causes even more problems I
just one per unit I think is really
tough it doesn't take into consideration
how many bedrooms um I'm not going to
fight this I don't think I can support
it because I'm I fear it causing more
problems than it than it solves I think
there's probably a better way to get
where we want to with this in terms of
uh abusing municipalities but I don't
know if this is
it representative Reed
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Walsh I do understand the
clamoring for more parking as someone
who frequently goes to Portsmith and
obviously has to park um in in conquered
frequently and I don't use the parking
garage as often as others um I
understand the frustration of not having
a place to park however um as was
brilliantly pointed out earlier today in
hearing uh by a question by
representative Wallace and then an
answer from person
testifying as frustrating as parking can
be we have a housing crisis we do not
have a parking crisis people don't die
of uh the freezing cold if they don't
have parking um people aren't you know
don't go into a situation where they
can't work or can't clean themselves or
can't do the things that are necessary
for life because they don't have parking
so I think our priority has to be taken
care of the parking and I don't think
this is necessarily A one- siiz fits-all
although I can understand that interpret
of course municipalities could simply
unit representative
yell thank you um I
definitely
[Music]
do kind of agree with representative
Reed however I wouldn't have used those
that the kind of
of of a
project
may need
May address the the needs of the people
that it's trying to Target right if they
might be targeting uh someone right next
to uh right on the
uh that that uh you know works right
next door is has a um has some some
business tied to it essentially where
it's just employees and so you have some
some other means of transportation or
you could be right next to a bus line or
all of these types of things I think
that the one- siiz fits all is mandating
the um the requirement of multiple um
parking spaces even when that your
target audience for that uh is not
needing of all of those parking spaces
and so I think that
uh I think that the flexibility really
uh allows for those those people that
are developing it that to understand
kind of who their target audience is if
their target audience is families with
children they're going to need you know
multiple cars they're going to design
that into their project and not leave
them kind of stranded on the side of the
road um but they if they're not
targeting that then they might not put
as many parking spaces um and so I kind
of leave that up to the kind of plans
and the development and then if the you
know and then the cost associated with
that with those you know do I need to
pay for that additional parking space if
I'm not going to be using it or um I
don't want to inflate artificially the
cost of that housing and so I think that
we just leave it up to the market if
those if if you build houses with only
uh one parking space and that's not
enough for you and you can't fill it
then I think that the market will will
uh decide and you're the value of those
property will be diminished if you if
you had just planned better uh when you
were in the planning process of your
development so I think that uh it will
all work itself out in the wash my
opinion thank you representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair I think it's
important to note that while uh this
provision would forbid the um
municipality from requiring more than
one parking space per unit uh there is
nothing in this in this proposal that
would prevent
uh
the municipality from allowing more than
one parking space per unit if the
developer chose to provide two parking
spaces per unit they could still do that
it's only that the
municipality uh could not require more
than
one representative
[Music]
walls again I'm not going to fight this
but I'll
leave one last comment on it based on a
comment I heard a minute ago solutions
to our housing crisis does not mean the
end result has to
be I don't know flawed development um
again there's nothing that stops a
municipality from putting an Ordnance in
that says they only need one themselves
now I'll leave it at
that represent birdie thank you Mr
chairman I
think the word was used housing crisis
we have a housing shortage I think
people would rather have a roof over
their head than an extra parking
space I consider um my opinion is one
parking space is the dimension of what a
bedroom can be um I think the market is
very smart I think the market can adjust
I think developers are going to build
what the needs of the community are
otherwise nobody's going to go and live
in that place so I believe strongly that
if if there is a need for more parking
if there's a need for visitor spots if
there's a need for um three parking
spaces per unit the developer is going
to build it I think the Market's very
powerful thing I will also say
that when
we I lost my train of thought I I think
the Market's a very powerful thing um I
think that we're going to adjust out of
this and one parking space is completely
reasonable I think sometimes
municipalities this is what I was going
to say I think sometimes municipalities
use parking as a way to deny a project
merely because they do not want the
project in their community and I don't
think that's fair um I think it is
borderline discriminatory I think we
need to as a state Clause some of that
power back because I think in some ways
that happens and we've heard that from
developers we've heard that from um
people that have come to testify so I'm
going to support this bill I think it's
it's a reasonable um restriction and I
think it's a
um it it's helping to balance the power
between the state municipalities
regarding
parking Mr chair representative D
Lorenzo thank you Mr chair this brings
to mind a development that we have in
the town of New Market the new market
Mills there is no parking on site um
there is a municipal lot where residents
of um the mill can park and it's part of
I guess it's part of the Lea park there
but
it's mixed with commercial other
commercial um Enterprises and and it
works um so with a with's a will is away
thank you representative Walsh and
representative Reed yeah last one on
this and that's my point about one siiz
fits-all in the cities large
municipalities you can get away with
zero parking because there are streets
everywhere there are parking garages
everywhere it works my issue in the in
the history of the development that I've
seen is in the more rural areas where we
still want this type of deel elment
where there on no roads they've got
their driveway or they're walking a half
a mile to to the the local Road it's a
we're looking at apples versus oranges
and trying to say that you can only do
this one per unit um in in two things
that aren't similar that's my only point
and again I would like to come to some
language that would solve the
municipalities that abuse but I don't
think this is
it representative Reed thank you um the
the chair uh kind of well said the
comments I had earlier which is what I
heard representative yela saying and
eventually got to the word market the
free market can fix this um that the
demand may one day be for more parking
but right now we know we all know the
demand is for more housing and we heard
testimony to the fact that you can put
housing where there currently is
required parking that goes empty empty
house empty parking in my own um
apartment complex is a matter of fact uh
to the point about New Market since
representative dealer and I share a
HomeTown um New Market is not a city it
does not have a parking garage and the
new market Mills despite not having the
parking as representative deal Enzo laid
out is the most desirable uh rentals in
in New Market it is considered extremely
desirable to live there and they go for
a very uh pretty penny so again uh one
per unit is enough and uh the market can
sort the rest
out representative
Gibbs thank you um I don't want to
belabor the point but uh as several of
us have said this provision would not
prevent a developer from providing more
than one parking space if it's judged
that more than one parking space is
needed it only prevents the municipality
from requiring more than one parking
space if in fact it's the type of
development that needs more parking then
the developer uh or owner landlord
whoever it might be um can do what they
need to do to provide
it representative Walsh thank you Mr
chair the market can't solve the problem
if it's already built and it doesn't
work thank
you representative
Damon I just want to note that vehicles
that require full-size parking spaces
are not the only mode of Transit that
people people might use and while it
frankly didn't occur to me in a timely
manner I wish we had a statement about
at least
encouraging bicycle
storage smaller Vehicles pedestrian
walkways Etc and I just need to put that
out there in the universe motorcycles
thank you all of which take much less
space than
cars represent
makoni uh Mr chairman could we uh move
the question we can't move the question
but I think I think we're finished up
okay so um all those in favor of the
amendment I'm going to make sure I get
it
right3 amendment number
0853 H please raise your
hand all those
opposed okay that's unanimous is there
any more discussion on the bill seeing
none I'm going to have the clerk call
the
roll on the question about to pass as
amended on House Bill
1400 uh Vice chair barui yes repres
representative makoni I representative
Walsh no clerk votes yes representative
yella yes representative D Lorenzo yes
representative Reed yes representative
Gibbs yes representative Damon yes
chairman Alexander yes motion passes 91
move
consent is there any objection to this
going on
consent will there be a Minority Report
will there be a Minority Report there's
no Minority Report on consent calendar
okay yes I yeah it's true yeah if
there's if there's a
right okay next up uh we have an
amendment ready for HB 1215 so I'm going
to call on representative Wallace for a
motion thank you thank you Mr chairman
it was just passed around you should
have it and if you need it there's
probably some more over by uh the North
End of the
room uh in any case I move ought to pass
and offer Amendment uh
2024-25
3H uh this amendment addresses the
changes we discussed earlier uh in
particular the moving the five to a
10-year exemption and uh on the
subdivision approvals and the requested
changes on appeals to the uh building
code board of appeals in the event that
the municipality has no building code
review board and uh everything else
earlier okay is there a discussion on
this wait did we have motions and
seconds for both the bill and the
amendment I haven't got a second yet I
second thank you okay so it's moved by
represent Wallace second by represent
Reed both the OTP and the and the
amendment
discussion on the
amendment seeing no discussion on the
amendment can I see a show of hands all
those in favor of the amendment please
hand those
opposed
unanimous does Mr Frost have something
to
glitch sorry uh Ben Frost housing uh Mr
mcin and I were going over the amendment
which is not what was sent to ol
uh it they changed the format
and the change presents a problem we
think uh the fix is simple and that is
to
delete uh the language on page two line
20 eliminate the new words local
amendments
too
um that was part of of the original bill
or an earlier amendment I can't remember
which and it was intended to work with
something else that has changed it no
longer really works um the objective
being
to
uh direct those uh decisions that are
made by local building
officials uh and it gets appealed if if
there's not a local building code board
of
appeals then send it straight to the
State Building Code review board um
because in the absence of a uh local
building code board of
appeals typically the Zoning Board of
adjustment serves as the local building
code board of appeals and they do not
have the expertise to be making
decisions on appeals of building
building code decisions uh
the State Board certainly
does specialized local bodies that
properly established as the building
code board of appeals do typically have
that expertise but the zba sitting as
the bcba Do
Not representative Reed thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr Frost once again um
understanding that we already will be
meeting next Friday I would withdraw my
second if the person moving would
withdraw his motion and um if the chair
was willing to recess it um with the
idea of preparing another and correct
Amendment for next Friday yes so um I'm
gonna go ahead and recess this public
hearing until next week and we'll or I'm
sorry ex session um we'll go ahead and
and put this up with the other um two
bills that I have planned for next
last yes I plan on for next week having
House Bill 1291 and House Bill 1399 to
be discussed in executive session so the
last bill that I'm hoping to get out of
committee today is House Bill 1065 so is
there an update from OS do we need to
recess 10 minutes or so
or all right let's take a 10-minute
2:15
e
okay so we're back so I'm going to open
up the executive session on House Bill
1065 and I'll rep I'll recognize
representative Damon to make a
motion
just um put turn on the mic I move to
pass House Bill 1065 is there a second I
second representative read seconds you
move an amendment and I introduce
amendment number
1046 and move to
OTP I second the amendment second the
amendment okay is there a discussion on
the the
amendment so I'm just going to
acknowledge as pointed out by
representative Yella that lines 8
through 10 are redundant but they are
not contradictory or in any way changing
the meeting they're actually just
repeating what is in the previous
sentence I would like the amendment to
go forward and if it's of concern we'll
sentence I concur with sorry I concur
with representative Damon's point of
view I understand the irritation of it
being uh redundant but I think that it's
still good language and it's upon us to
to pass good language okay is there
amendment seeing none um all those in
favor of amendment number
1046 please raise your
opposed that was in favor right okay all
right we're unanimous on
that um okay so any discussion on the
underlying bill as
amended I'm
H 1065 thank you so much yep regarding
fire
sprinklers so I think this is an
important bill um we had um some public
testimony that some cities and towns
require more stringent than State Fire
code regarding residential sprinkler
systems I think that's really important
that we make it clear that they cannot
be more stringent than the state fire
code I think that is part of the process
of of of what's been holding up some of
this development and expansion of um
units from buildings of two two units to
buildings of
four representative Reed I agree it's
very important and also it was raised to
me since adus are my favorite topic
these days um that a a person owning a
home that wishes to maybe add an Adu
within or separate their home into an
Adu uh or two or more even if it was
allowed might be prevented because of
the sprinklers uh by a town so I think
it's very important and especially as
Vella um thank you Mr chair um
I am not a super big
fan of the language in the first
paragraph um I think
that for it uh existing buildings um or
existing buildings with no more than
four dwelling units and then I think the
after purposes it should just be a
period
I understand that it's not it it's
not in any way
diminishing the overall intent and I
feel like you know Clarity in the law is
a value but it's it's also not not um
it's not harming the overall impact and
I feel like
the addition of 17 through
19 uh on this bill is far outweighs any
negative uh uh from the language uh
qualms I have with the first paragraph
because I do think that
um or I am aware of at least one
personal person that was consider one
person I knew that was
considering
um
having
uh two unit structure converted into a
three unit structure for renting and
found and was
specifically
uh disheartened that they would need to
uh uh do the
sprinklers and so the project just never
got anywhere close to off the ground
because of that immense
expense and so um you know one less unit
because of this and um that or one or
two less units because of this that I am
directly aware of from from someone
that's providing housing in the state
right now um and that
is um you know a big deal and I'm glad
that the state is taking some some
action on that and I do worry that um
even though someone in the in the te
testimony in in this um testimony on
this Bill said that that you know
municipalities won't be making these
ordinances because it's in the
nitty-gritty we have evidence that they
do and I don't agree that they you know
ha have uh more experts at the local
minicipal that we have access to at the
at the state level as far as health and
safety uh is concerned and
so um for that reason I don't I think
they're kind of out of their depth if
they go into this and say like no we
know better than you as far as as far as
sprinklers um and so uh for that reason
I'm going to be supporting this this
amendment representative
Gibbs thank you uh I just wanted to say
that I find the language in the
amendment to be comprehensible and uh it
does something that I think uh will be
important for um increas in units which
we obviously need and for those reasons
uh I do support
it representative Walsh thank you Mr
chair I'm going to support this um but
but and I may have missed the hearing on
this because I've been unfortunately
double booked the authority having
jurisdiction ahjs it's called is a
separate section of the code so in spite
of this language is there anything
that's going to stop an ahj from doing
what he wants regardless what's
ah just a question to throw out there
again i' I've gone down this road before
and as soon as long as the ahj is part
of the fire code anything we pass is
very difficult to actually adopt so
we'll give it a shot wish us
well representative Damon
thank you two things I'm sorry I'm not
familiar with the acronym what are you
referring to represent W it's called
it's in the it's in the uh NFPA 1 it's
called The Authority having jurisdiction
which is basically the chief or design
in every municipality I'm sorry I did
not articulate and the way it's
described is you know they basically
have sole authority to based on
individual circumstances have the final
word represent D go ahead the other
thing I wanted to do is just put into
the record a uh appreciation to the
State Fire Marshall and the building
code review board for their considerable
assistance as we work through
this represent mononi thank you Mr
chairman um I with the addition of the
um of no more than um in a in a
structure I believe is what we added on
there um this is this is Landmark this
is something new to have the Fire
Marshall and en codes people to say
let's let's give this a try this is
fabulous you you have no idea how much
this will add to you I'm in full
support I love this okay any other
discussion seeing none I'm going to have
um the clerk call the rooll the motion
was ought to pass as amended by
representative Damon with amendment
number
1046 Vice chairman barudi yes
representative makoni I representative
Walsh yes Clerk votes yes representative
yella yes representative D Lorenzo yes
representative Reed yes representative
Gibbs yes representative Damon yes
chairman Alexander yes unanimous 10 Z
okay is there any objection to this
going on
consent
wonderful um so that will go on consent
um are there any other I so I we have um
as a committee we technically have four
bills left there's one Senate bill that
we've received that I plan on hearing
after crossover um there's other
chairman on the committee that have
advised me that that's probably the
right thing to do so we don't have
redundant meeting dates um and then the
other three is the one by representative
Wallace HB 1215 which we're going to get
an amendment on and then we have um HB
1291 um which we've put a lot of
discussion in I want to give everybody
enough time to digest that and then HB
1399 um there's an amend m m that
representative MC Williams passed around
to the committee today that I'd like
everybody to take a look at and um be
prepared to discuss um next Friday
during our work session so I'm going to
notice a work session next Friday
starting at 10: and then an executive
session to follow that and that
hopefully will be the last day that
we'll get all the bills out of our
committee representative Walsh yeah
thank you Mr chair um yeah when I
suggested maybe waiting till have the
crossover that was with the Assumption
we were done all our business but seeing
us out we are coming here anyway for
other bills if you wanted to roll the
dice and and do the Senate bill as well
we may not get anything after crossover
so just something for you to think about
okay the only reason I hold usually
until crossover is if I get eight bills
from the Senate before I hear them and
exec them and then after cross over they
give me one more that that's all I was
trying to get yeah I I I think there's
other bills in the Senate that I'd like
to see at least come to this committee
so um I'm going to hold off on those
anything
all right perfect well thank you for
your work this is awesome we got four
bills on consent um really big deal so
congratulations everyone and thank you
week